TO CALL THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ORDER. AGAIN WE
ARE IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS
FOR OUR HEARING WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT HEARING-
WE'RE ASKING EVERYBODY WHO
ATTENDS FROM THE PUBLIC TO
RESPECT THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. EVERYBODY WHO
ATTENDS FROM THE PUBLIC WHETHER
YOU ARE HERE- PERSON PERSONALLY
OR- OVER THE WILL HAVE ONE. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA ARE ALL APPEARING
REMOTELY. MEMBERS MAY WHO HAVE
REQUESTED IN ADVANCE TO APPEAR
MOLDING CAN DO SO BECAUSE THIS
IS AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
THERE ALSO BE NO VOTE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY. SO TODAY WE
ARE HEARING FOR BILLS SENATE
BILL EIGHTY FIVE SENATE BILL
EIGHTY SIX SENATE BILL NINETY
TWO AND SENATE BILL NINETY
THREE WE HAVE PANELISTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AS WELL HOW DO YOU TO THE
BILL'S WHAT I'D LIKE TO PROPOSE
IS THAT WE HEAR ALL FOUR OF THE
BILLS TOGETHER AND THEN MEMBERS
CAN OBVIOUSLY ASK QUESTIONS ON
ANY OF THE ITEMS WERE MADE
COMMENTS ON ANY OF THE ITEMS AT
THAT PARTICULAR TIME AFTER
WE'VE HEARD. TESTIMONY FROM
EVERYBODY- TODAY WERE WERE VERY
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT SB EIGHTY
FIVE WHICH IS OUR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR WILD FIRE
PACKAGE I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS-
IN EARLY DOWN PAYMENT ON OUR
WILD FIRE WORK THAT WE KNOW AND
WE WERE SHARING A PRESS REPORTS
ON HOW DRY IT ALREADY IS THIS-
THIS YEAR. NOW THERE'S A LACK
OF WATER SO WE BELIEVE THAT
TAKING EARLY ACTION MAKES LOT
OF SENSE I DO WANT TO THANK OUR
CHARTER BUDGET SUB SURE OF
NUMBERS SUBJECT OF THE THREE
FOUR SEVEN SANTA MONICA FOR ALL
HIS HARD WORK IN THE COMMITTEES
HARD WORK ON THIS. PARTICULAR
ISSUE BUT GLAD THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO REACH EARLY AGREEMENT
WITH THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON A WILDFIRE
PACKAGE SO- ON THAT AND WE HAVE
A COUPLE OTHER BILLS- AROUND
THE TIME YOU KNOW FOLLOW UP ON
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS WELL
AS OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT. FROM LAST YEAR AND
THAT OUR HOSPITALITY WORKERS
RIGHT TO RETURN OF BOTH OF
THOSE BILL THE POUND WORK AND
WE ALREADY DID IN THIS JUNE
BUDGET FROM LAST YEAR SO. WITH
THAT I'M START A FEW FOR VICE
HAS IN YOUR COM AND FIFTY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMENTS AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO FORM. FOR I
THINK MEDICARE MEMBERS TODAY WE
HAVE TO GO PRIORITY THAT WE
MUST ADDRESS RIGHT. ONE WE NOW
THAT WE ARE IN FOR A SEVERE
WILDFIRE SEASON. DUE TO THE
CURRENT DROUGHT. US WE NEED TO
USE A MEDICAID. IMPROVING LAW
FIVE OF TO A- TO ENSURE. THE WE
DO NOT HAVE A READ. OF FIRE YOU.
WHEN PEOPLE'S LIFE ARE DAVIS BY
I OF CONTROL. AND SO. AS WE ARE
SEEING LIGHT AT THE END THE-
FROM THE PANDA. YOU MUST CAN
HELP THOSE. WHO ARE IN NEED OF
US. TO GET SOMEBODY THAT WILL
TO SIR AS A BRIDGE. CONNECTING
THEM INTO IN A- THAT BEGINNING
TO REOPEN. I DO WANNA. THAT THE
LEAD. SHOULD NOT BE IMPOSING
NEW COST BURDENS MANDATES AND
LIABILITIES ON BUSINESSES THAT
JUST AS THEY ARE EMERGING. FROM
THIS PAST YEAR OF DEVASTATION
OTHER BUSINESSES. SOMETIMES
LESS IS MORE AND THIS IS THE
TIME WHEN SACRAMENTO SHOULD LET
BUSINESSES MAKE THEIR COMEBACK.
I LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING THAT
THESE MEASURES THESE MATTERS
AND I TO ME TODAY I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
WHEN YOU COMMENTS THE MEMBER.
IF NOT LET'S START WITH MISS
LEAVE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING MR TANG-
CHURCH HANG BY SURF ON THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ERICA
LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I AM DELIGHTED WITH
SEVERAL COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND WE
WILL BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PRESENTATION- AND AS YOU SAID
MR KING I WILL BE PRESENTING AT
ALL FOR BILLS- BACK TO BACK
AND- OPENING IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS AT. AFTER THAT. THE
FIRST BILL SB EIGHTY. IS A
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THAT AMENDS
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
ON THIS BILL INCLUDES
PROVISIONS FOR THE WILDFIRE
PACKAGE AGREED UPON BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT WILL ENABLE
IMPORTANT FIRE MITIGATION
PROJECTS TO BE ACCELERATED INTO
THE CURRENT YEAR. THE WILD FACT
FIRE PACKAGE COMES ON THE HEELS
OF A DEVASTATING TWENTY TWENTY
FIRE SEASON IN WHICH NINE
THOUSAND WHILE WILDFIRES
BURNED. OVER FOUR MILLION ACRES
ACROSS THE STATE THAT'S MORE
THAN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIRE SEASONS
COMBINED. CALIFORNIA FACES A
SIMILARLY DANGEROUS AND
POTENTIALLY RECORD SETTING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON.
IT'S WHAT THE CONTEXT OF
INCREASED FIRE SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR WHAT FOR A
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
PACKAGE. WITH THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION AND EARLY
ACTION TO AS HE SAID MR TANK
CELEBRATE FIRE PREVENTION
FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS NOW-
AFTER COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY NOW INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
A BROAD SET OF IT INVESTMENTS.
THIS PACKAGE INCLUDES. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE TWO.
PROJECTS THAT WILL HELP CREATE
RESILIENT PLAN STATE WHY.
MEDICAID KATIS. WILDFIRES AND
THEIR CASCADING CLIMENT
CONSEQUENCES LIKE DAMAGES TO
WATERSHED MUD SLIDE. MUDSLIDES
AND LOTS OF HABITAT. IT ALSO
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT MILLION TO FIND STATE
PROJECTS AND GRANTS TO LOCAL
ENTITIES FOR EMERGENCY FUEL
BREAKS TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
AND SENSITIVE AREAS AGAINST THE
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE. THIS
PACKAGE INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION INTENDED TO LEVERAGE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
AND FEDERAL FUNDS FOR A TOTAL
OF ONE HUNDRED MILLION. DOLLARS
FOR PILOT PROJECTS TO SUPPORT
LOW INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
HOMEOWNERS IN ACCESSING
RETROFITS TO HARDEN THEIR HOMES
THESE RETROFITS THAT HARDEN
HOME AGAINST EMBERS WILL RESULT
IN A SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
CHANCE OF SURVIVAL IN A
WILDFIRE. THIS PACKAGE ALSO
PROVIDES TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO
HELP STIMULATE FOR SECTOR
INVESTMENT AND ECONOMIC GROWTH-
THIS INCLUDES AN INITIAL
SIXTEEN MILLION TRANSFERRED TO
THE CLIMATE CATALYST FUND TO
OFFER LOW INTEREST LENDING TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT HAVE GREEN
IDEAS THAT MAY NOT BE IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU'RE CONNECTED ENOUGH TO
COMPETE FOR VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING. THERE'S SIX MILLION
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS TO DEVELOP COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS PROFESSIONAL
CERTIFICATIONS AND TRAINING.
AND ANOTHER THREE MILLION FOR
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK
FOR THE STATE'S BUDGET
UTILIZATION POLICIES AND
PRIORITIES. AMONG OTHER THINGS.
RENDITION TO THE WILDFIRE
PROVISIONS THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR ALSO INCLUDES THREE-
THREE POINT THREE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO FIND A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND MICROGRAM
PROGRAM FOR SMALL MID SIZED AND
UNDERSERVED FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT ALSO ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO ISSUE FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE PER CHILD ONE TIME
STIPENDS TO CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM PROVIDERS. IF FORTY FOR
THIS PROVIDER TYPE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
CHILD CARE STIPEND PAYMENTS
THAT WERE PAST PREVIOUSLY. AN
EARLY ACTION- AND INCLUDES
POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FOR
TRY WELFARE. TO PROVIDE. COPING
NINETY CONDEMN SUPPORT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND THEIR CARE GOT
CARE GIVERS. SO MOVING ON TO
ASK THE EIGHTY SIX WHICH IS THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS CLEAN UP
TRAILER BILL. AB EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH WAS ENACTED IN ACTIVE IN
LATE FEBRUARY ESTABLISH THE
GOLDEN STATE'S UP GOLDEN STATE
GRANT PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES ONE
TIME RENT PAYMENTS IN THE
AMOUNT OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO QUALIFY AND LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS ON THE SS I SS P.
CAPPY PROGRAMS AS WELL AS TO
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE CALVERTS
PROGRAM. THIS BILL INCLUDES
CLEAN UP PROVISIONS THAT ENABLE
THE STATE TO THE MINISTER THE
ONE TIME ACCESS TO GOLDEN STATE
GRANT PAYMENTS TO ELIGIBLE
RECIPIENTS. WILL ALSO EXTENDS
THE CAPITA VERBAL ATTESTATION
FLEXIBILITY THROUGH THE END OF
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY DUE TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THIS FLEXIBILITY IS CURRENTLY
NEEDED TO SUPPORT CAPITA
APPLICANTS GIVEN SOCIAL
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION OFFICES.
STILL REMAIN CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC. IT PROVIDED A PART OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ABOARD TO CON
PERSON. OF THE DEPARTMENT OVER.
TO NOTIFY OF THE- FOR OTHER
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL
BENEFITS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO- THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT AND FEDERAL TAX
STIMULUS CREDITS. AND FINALLY
THIS BILL PROVIDES ONE POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
ALLOW EMERGENCY PLACEMENT
FOSTER. CARE GIVERS TO CONTINUE
TO BE PAID BEYOND THE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS. FOR
INSTANCES IN WHICH THE FOSTER
PARENT APPROVAL PROCESS HAS
BEEN DELAYED DUE TO CULVERT
NINETEEN. ARE MOVING ON TO SB
NINETY TO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT TRAILER BILL. SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE ABOUT A
TRAILER BILL FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT REALIGNED TO
KAREN SUPERVISION OF YOUTH THAT
HAVE COMMITTED SPECIFIED
OFFENSES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION- CDCR. DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE FOR DJJ FOR
COUNTY STARTING JULY ONE OF
THIS YEAR. SB NINETY TWO WHICH
IS UP FOR CONSIDERATION TODAY
IS AN IMPORTANT FOLLOW ON TO
ASK THE EIGHT TWENTY THREE AND
ADDRESSES CRITICAL AREAS. THAT
ARE NECESSARY TO HELP THE
SUCCESSFUL REALIGNMENT OF YOUTH
TO COUNTIES. WHILE THE DANGER
WAS WILL CLOSE INTAKE AND JULY
ONE OF THIS YEAR WITH LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS- PURSUANT TO SB
EIGHT TO THREE SB NINETY TWO
SPECIFIES THE DJ WILL CLOSE
ENTIRELY ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THIS CALL
REQUIRES THE DIRECTOR OF DJJ TO
DEVELOP A PLAN FOR THE TRANSFER
OF THE REMAINING YOUTH WERE
UNABLE TO DISCHARGE PRIOR TO
THE CLOSURE OF DJJ- AND THAT'S
ESTIMATED TO BE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY USE- THAT DO NOT HAVE
A CHARGER HEARING DATE THAT
FALLS BEFORE JUNE THIRTIETH. OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THIS BILL
ALSO. A FRAME FOR SECURITY.
FACILITIES FOR HIGHER NEED
YOUTH CONSISTENT WITH INTENT
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN SB. EIGHTY
THREE- YOU THE SIGN TO THE
FACILITIES WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
TREATMENT AND EDUCATION THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO THEIR INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS. AND FINALLY THIS BILL
PROPOSES OTHER TECHNICAL AND
CONFORMING CHANGES. THEN MOVING
ON TO THE LAST BILL WHICH IS SB
NINETY THREE- RETIRING IN
RETENTION AND DISPLACED WORKERS
TRAILER BILL. THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC- AS WE HAVE
STATED AND- WIDELY KNOWN
HAZARDOUS. IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THE NEGATIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON EMPLOYEES IN THE
HOSPITALITY AND BUSINESS
SERVICES INDUSTRIES WHO ARE
LAID OFF DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
DESERVEDLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
HALF. EMPLOYERS TO OFFER NEWLY
ESTABLISHED POSITIONS TO
QUALIFY FOR OUR EMPLOYEES THAT
WERE LAID OUT FOR COULD BE
NINETEEN RELATED REASONS WITHIN
FIVE BUSINESS DAYS OF
ESTABLISHING THAT POSITION.
THAT POSITION ON THROUGH THE
END OF- THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
SO THREE TO THIRTY TWENTY FOUR.
ELIGIBLE EMPLOYEES DEFINED IN
THE BILL ARE THOSE WHO WORK FOR
THE EMPLOYER FOR SIX MONTHS OR
MORE DURING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
CALENDAR YEAR AND WE'RE LAID
OFF DUE TO A PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTIVE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
ORDER. LACK OF BUSINESS OR
ANOTHER ECONOMIC NON
DISCIPLINARY REASON BECAUSE BY
IS IS SUBJECT TO THE
CERTAIN HOTEL AND PRIVATE
CLUBS. LARGE EVENT CENTERS
AIRPORTS AIRPORT HOSPITALITY
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
BUSINESSES THAT PROVIDE
JANITORIAL MAINTENANCE OR
SECURITY SERVICES TO COMMERCIAL
BUILDING OF. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATE SIX MILLION FOR THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO ENFORCE
WITH BELL. THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE HAS THE
EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION TO
ENFORCE A SECTION UPON
RECEIVING A COMPLAINT. I KNOW
CANNOT BE BROUGHT UNDER THESE
PROVISIONS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS ON THE FOR BILLS AND AS
I PREVIOUSLY STATED I JOINED BY
SEVERAL COLLEAGUES ARE SUBJECT
EXPERTS AND CAN ANSWER. AND
MORE DETAILS ON THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD L. L. GOOD
MORNING CHAD ALAMO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
SIMILARLY I'M JOINED BY SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES WILL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON
ONE OF THE FOR EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE BILLS- BUT OUR OFFICE
HAS NO SPECIFIC COMMENTS OF AT
THIS TIME- ABOUT THE THIS OF
THE CORPORATE ARE HAPPY TAKE
ARE WHAT WERE CAN ANSWER CURE
NOW WORKING PRACTICE- OF COURSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK ALL
TURN BACK TO THE FOR QUEST. MR
FOR. I'M RT COMMITTEE- ON SB
EIGHTY FIVE- WHAT IS THE ACTION
FOR PER HERE IS THAT I CATCH UP
ON WHAT WAS PROMISED UNDER S.
B. NINE OH ONE IS THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING. HI THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION I WILL TURN OVER
THE SPECIFICS TO MY COLLEAGUE-
IT'S EVEN WELL I BELIEVE THE
COMBINED. HM MORNING THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING STEVEN BENSON
BERMAN FOR- THE EACH THE CAP
AND ARGUE G. R. F. PORTION A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE NO. IS KIND
OF A CATCH UP IF YOU WILL IT'S
TO ME SB NINE A ONE PORTION.
THAT WAS LEFT OUT OF THE BUNCH
WENT MISSING AND I. THE SO AT
THE END OF THE WHAT IS YOUR
FUND PIECES REPORTER. BACK AND
THAT IS THAT THE HAVE THE
GENERAL PIECES A- BY THE I KNOW
WHAT. HAD A ONE BILLION OVER
FOR YEARS AND SO THIS WOULD
WHICH WOULD BE A- UP OF WELL
WHAT WASN'T. AND IN. THE LAST
BUDGET THAT WAS DONE. CORRECT.
FRET OKAY- AND THEN DO YOU. ANY
ANY SENSE- OF AND MAYBE THE IS
A NOT THE PURVIEW OF THIS HERE
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE
NEXT DID YOU DO IT. AND CAN OF
THIS AND. NINE NINE A ONE
PROMISED TO DO ANOTHER- WE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THE NEXT IN
THE GYM BUDGET. SO THE GUY BURN
PROPOSED TO CA. MEETING THOSE
S. NINE ONE OF NATION'S AS WELL
AS TO CONTINUE IT AN ADDITIONAL
FEW YEAR BEYOND WHAT SB WANTED
ITSELF OKAY SO THERE'S A
THERE'S AN EXPECTED THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE FUTURE BUDGETS
WILL WILL MAINTAIN THIS A
PROMISE UNDER HAS BEEN AT A ONE.
CORRECT OKAY- IN IN TERMS OF-
PRESCRIBED BURNING BURNS AND- A
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WE KNOW
THOSE ARE OUR OFFICE THE PROVEN
OF FOREST FIRE PREVENTION
TECHNIQUES- I DON'T PROGRESS IN
A- ANY GUARANTEES IN THIS BILL
THAT FUNDING WILL GO TO. TO
THESE MITIGATION AND PREVENTION
EFFORTS. SO WHAT INSURANCE IS
THAT WE HAVE THAT THIS FUNDING.
WILL ACTUALLY USE FOR
PRESCRIBED BURNS AND ENVELOPE
AND FORCE MANAGEMENT- AND IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT ACTUALLY STREAMLINES.
PROVIDES STREAMLINING I'M
THROUGH A PROCESS. SO THERE'S
FIFTEEN MILLION MEDISPA TO
PRESCRIBE FOR HIM. WITHIN THE
EARLY AFTER PACKET WHICH IN
ADDITION- THE FOREST HEALTH
FIRE PER. AND GRANT FUNDING-
CAN GO TOWARDS GRANTS THAT
WOULDN'T PROJECT THAT MIGHT BE.
PRESCRIBED BURN PRESCRIBER AND
ISN'T AS A COURSE YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE VARIOUS METHODS CAN BE
USED FOR FUEL REDUCTION. FOR
FIRE METHOD OPERATING GO BREAK
THINGS THAT SO- I THAT THERE'S
NO LIKINGS SPLIT IS TO HELP OF
THAT FUNDING WHICH FOR FIRE
WHILE THIS DEPEND ON THE PRICE
THAT ARE PART. IN ONES GET. BUT
BUT WE WOULD EXPECT THAT YOU
KNOW NUMBER OF THOSE PROJECTS
INCLUDE PRESCRIBED FIRES WELL
IT'S KIND OF A MECHANIZED-
APPROACHES TO PEOPLE'S FUTURE.
AND THAT'S THE I GUESS THE BIG
CAN. IS THAT YOU KNOW MUCH OF
THE FUN WILL BE OUT. TO THE
TECHNIQUES VERSUS OTHER THINGS
THAT MAY NOT. BE AS EFFECTIVE
BUT- MOVING ON TO THE- TO SB
ADDED TO THE DJJ REALIGNMENT-
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME INPUT IN
TERMS OF- YOU KNOW IF THE
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN CONSULTED-
AND ANDY'S REALIGNMENT PLANS.
HI YES I'M GOING TO TURN UP
OVER SPIKE ALAN HULETT. ALISON
SHE DEPART OF FINE I COUNTY
BEEN. THERE'S BEEN A OF A I'LL
TRYOF STATE THAT. BEEN IN THE
IN TURN OF- UP FOR ME THAT THAT
NINETY AS A NOW AND TELL ME HOW
BEEN IN THE IN ENGAGED IN THAT
PROCESS. OKAY AND THEN MAYBE
YOU CAN- SAYS THAT HAVE YOU
CAN'T CAN YOU. FIX WHY THIS IS
BEING IN A IN A BUDGET BILL NOW
OF. WAITING THE POLICY
COMMITTEES AND DOES THE REGULAR
PROCESS. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- AND THERE'S
A COUPLE OF REASONS WHY IT
MAKES SENSE TO DO SB NINETY TWO
AND MAKE THESE CHANGES NOW I'M
THE FIRST IS THAT THE-
REALIGNMENT. OF AND DID OF USE
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE GONE
TO DJJ STARTS JULY FIRST SO WE
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE ABLE
TO. WAIT OUTSIDE BECAUSE
COUNTIES WILL BE EVEN OF-
PROVIDING TO THESE YOUTH IN
SERVICE TO THESE YOU STARTING
ONE. AND THERE WAS A KIND OF A
RECOGNITION THAT THERE WOULD
NEED TO BE A FOLLOW ON BILL-
FOR EXAMPLE- UP PART OF WHAT SB
NINETY TWO DOZEN IS OUR A
FRAMEWORK FOR SECURITY YOU
TREATMENT FACILITIES. AND- IN
B. E. TWO THREE ONE WHICH WAS A
LAW YEAR AND THERE WAS A GOAL
OR INTENT LANGUAGE BEST. THAT
SUCH- A FRAMEWORK WOULD COME
FORWARD BY MARCH FIRST SO
OBVIOUSLY A LITTLE BIT. LATER
THAN PLANNED BUT SO THAT'S AN
ESSENTIALLY WHY THIS IS THAT
NEEDS TO BE ACCOMPLISHED NOW
AND THERE'S ALL THERE ARE ALSO
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS- WHICH IS
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING FUNDING TO
COUNTIES- IN DOING THAT SO.
HOPEFULLY THAT. ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION- BABY I'M GONNA THE L.
A. L. THEIR AND ON ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND PLANS CURRENT AS
THEY SAY FOR REALIGNMENT WHAT
IS YOUR NOW. THANK YOU ARE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO- HIM THAT
QUESTION OVER VICE CHAIR TO MY
COLLEAGUE LUKE BECAUSE MARK.
MOREOVER THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE ARE NOT
TAKING A POSITION ON THE
SPECIFIC- PIECE OF LEGISLATION-
WE HAVE WORKED OFTEN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE.
ADMINISTRATION DESPITE ON THAT
PROPOSAL AND THE WORKING I
THOUGHT TO WOULD BE EIGHTY SOME
SORT OF FOLLOW- THAT WE ARE NOT
A POSITION SPECIFIC LUXURY.
AFFECTS QUESTION YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THE BILLING WHAT WAS YOUR
IF YOU CAN REFRESH MY MEMORY
WAS YOUR- OR WHAT WAS THE- YEAR
PER SPECT ON. THE RIVER PLAN.
ACTUALLY WE ARE SOME CONCERN ON
SPACE LANGUAGE- AS WELL AS THE
FIRST CAMERA WHETHER WHAT
THEY'RE PROBABLY APPROACH WOULD
BE TO TAKE RESTORE THE OF YOUR
JUST WE DID NOT RAISE- SPECIFIC
RECOMMEND. ON THAT REQUIRED ME
ITSELF MORE A WITH LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER IN TERMS OF
FINANCIAL THAT COULD ISSUES
TRYING TO. AT HOW WHEN WE
SHOULD BE STRUCTURED. FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG I BELIEVE
YOUR QUESTION WAS WHY WE'RE
DOING THIS NOW VERSUS IN JUNE.
YOUR ORIGINAL QUESTION- SO BUT
ALSO WHETHER THE COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN ON EVERY AND WHAT WHAT
COUNTY INPUT HAS BEEN PROVIDED-
AS WELL I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR
THE LAST PART OF WHAT WHAT WHAT
COUNTY INPUT HAS BEEN PROVIDED
IN THE COUNTY. SURE A LOT OF
WHAT WE'VE GOTTEN FROM THEM GOT
IT THANK YOU- SO THEY DJJ
REALIGNMENT EFFORT WAS STARTED
LAST YEAR ONE OF THE MAIN
PROVISIONS THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE INCLUDED. IN LAST YEAR'S
BILL WITH THE SECURE TRACK
POLICY AND THIS IS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO THE COURTS AND THE
COUNTIES WHAT TO DO WITH THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
SENT TO DJJ- WHEN DJ IS NO
LONGER AN OPTION- AT THE TIME
THE LEGISLATURE WAS PUSHING TO
INCLUDE THIS POLICY- WE REALIZE
THAT WE NEEDED A BROADER
STAKEHOLDER INPUT. AND BETWEEN
THE SUMMER AND THE PUT UP UNTIL
THIS POINT WE RECEIVED FEEDBACK
FROM JUVENILE COURT JUDGE
JUDGES-THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS C. SACK AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS IN
DEVELOPING THIS- AND THE REASON
WHY IT'S NEEDED NOW- IS BECAUSE
INTAKE FOR DJJ. SET TO CLOSE IN
JUNE. AND THE COURTS SEEKING
THIS. AS THEY ARE- DEALING WITH
CASES- AT THE MOMENT. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT- AND LASTLY IF I COULD
JUMP TO YOU- SB NINETY THREE-
AND CERTAINLY THIS BILL
PROPOSES- SIGNIFICANT
RESTRICTIONS ON EMPLOYERS-
HIRING ABILITY- AND THERE'S A
NEW LIABILITY IMPLICATIONS AS
WELL- WHAT OPTIONS UNDER THIS
BILL WILL EMPLOYERS HAVE TO
APPEAL ANY ACTIONS TAKEN
AGAINST THEM- IF THEY'VE
ALREADY MADE EFFORTS TO RE HIRE
FORMER EMPLOYEES. AND ARE THERE
ANY INCENTIVES PROVIDED TO
BUSINESSES TO REHIRE EMPLOYEE
FORMER EMPLOYEES AS WELL- YES
MR FONG I WILL TURN THAT
QUESTION OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
DAVID WALTER WHO IS JOINING US
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. GOOD
MORNING VICE CHAIR OF THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS WITH OTHER ON
CITATIONS OR A SET SINCE
THEY'RE MADE AGAINST EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYERS WOULD HAVE FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO ALL APPEAL. ANY
IS A PROPOSAL ASSESSMENT AND
HAVE A FULL DUE PROCESS HEARING
ALL BEFORE ANY SUCH YOU BETTER
BECAME FINAL- ADDITIONALLY ON
HIS YOU'LL NOTE THERE'S
EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO ENFORCE
THESE PROVISIONS AND SO IT'S
OUR NORMAL PRACTICE. OF TRYING
TO INTERVENE EARLY WITH AN
EMPLOYER WILL BE GET NOTICE OF
ALL POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS SUCH
THAT THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WALK TO CURE IT IS SOON AS
YOU KNOW WE'RE. WE KNOW ABOUT
IT AND NOTIFY THEM. SO THERE IS
THAT SO THERE IS A RIGHT TO GET
IT IS THAT THERE IS NO RIGHT TO
ACTION HERE IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT PAGA IS NOT. INVOLVED
IN THIS. WHAT THE WAY TO THE
LEGISLATION IS WRITTEN PROVIDES
THAT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS
EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION. AND
THAT THESE ARE THE OLD THE
PROVISIONS ARE PROVIDED AND
TWENTY EIGHT TEN POINT EIGHT.
WOULD BE THE ONLY- MEANS FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF. OF THESE SAW
PROVISIONS WHICH- SUNSET AT THE
END OF LONG. OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND- ONLY RELATED
TO- CODE RELATED SEPARATION
POINT. OKAY AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION I GUESS- IS CAN YOU
WAY N. ON THE POTENTIAL ON
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS BILL
IN TERMS OF HOW TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
SQUARE WITH THE FACT THAT. MANY
OF THESE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
HIRED AT WILL. HAVE YOU HEARD
THAT ARGUMENT OR ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT AT ALL. THAT SAID
OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE ABILITY TO CALL CREATE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS THAT-
THAT TOGGLE BEYOND WHATEVER ALL
EMPLOYMENT ARRANGEMENT OR EXIST
BETWEEN AN EMPLOYER AND AN
EMPLOYEE AND- THAT'S YOU KNOW.
SIMILAR PROVISIONS ARE
THROUGHOUT THE LABOR CODE AND
AS FAR AS I AM MY UNDERSTANDING
HAVE BEEN HELD TO BE
CONSTITUTIONAL IN THE PAST.
OKAY I GUESS WE'LL HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION- BUT I THINK THAT'S
A CONCERN THAT THAT THAT I
HAVE- THAT THIS BILL MAY IMPAIR
THAT PRE EXISTING OBLIGATIONS.
UNDER SOME OF THE CAUSES OF THE
US AND CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
BUT- I CELEBRATED THE ANSWERED
THANK YOU TAKE CARE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO MISTER
COOPER AND THE MISTER RAMOS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- LAST
WEEK REFORM TORQUE- THAT A
COMPROMISE BEEN REACH WITH THE
GOVERNOR ON THE WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCY BILL. THERE
WAS NO MENTION DISCUSSION OF
THE OTHER TRAILER BILLS RELATED
TO JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT
ARE RE HIRING OF DISPLACED
WORKERS. THAT WE'RE HEARING
TODAY IN FACT WE WERE NOT AWARE
OF THESE ISSUES UNTIL FRIDAY AT
FIVE TWENTY SIX. WHAT ARE CHIEF
OF STAFFS RECEIVE YOUR GENDER
WHICH INCLUDED THESE ISSUES.
WITH BY THE MERITS OR FLAWS
THESE PROPOSALS THIS PROCESS
GIVES US VERY LITTLE TIME TO
REVIEW AND ANALYZE THESE
PROPOSAL'S. IMPACT WE WILL HAVE
OUR DISTRICTS I'M NOT SURE THE
RUSHES- IN ADDITION WORRY ONCE
AGAIN ADDRESSING POLICY ISSUES
THEY'RE NOT BUDGET ISSUES. THIS
CONTACTED TIME PERIOD OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS- GOING TO- APS
SB NINETY TWO OF THAT SOME
QUESTIONS- WE TALK ABOUT SECURE
YOU'VE. TREATMENT FACILITIES-
THREE COUNTY THIS THEIR OWN.
BUT YOU'VE GOT FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY. SO YOU HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT SECURE TREATMENT
FACILITY IS THAT CORRECT. THIS
IS ALLISON HERE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE STILL THERE ARE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES I'M AND THERE IS
A- MORE LICENSING REQUIREMENT
THAT COUNTIES WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE SOME STRUCTURE IN PLACE
HOWEVER SB. NINETY TO PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN OF COUNTY
HEALTH MY MEET THAT WERE. I'M
AND THAT INCLUDES CON THE WITH
OTHER- IF THEY WANTED TO SOME
TYPE OF REGIONAL APPROACH.
AMBASSADOR ARE AT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY IN THERE ARE
OPTIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
COUNTIES WOULD MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT BUT RIGHT NOW THE
DJJ LOOK AT SOME OTHER PROGRAMS
ARE AWARD WINNING PROGRAMS THEY
HAVE FOR REHABILITATION FOR
THESE FOLKS. AND THAT'S COME
ABOUT BECAUSE DJS BEEN SUED AS
HAS DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS OVER
THE YEARS BY THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE SO. THEY'VE BEEN. A LOT
OF LOS IN. THE TENS OR HUNDREDS
OF MILLION DOLLARS PAID OUT TO
GET THEM TO WHERE THEY ARE. SO
NOW THAT IS GOING DOWN THE
COUNTIES- ROUTING THE COUNTY
JAILS BEING SUED ALREADY BY THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE. MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS STATEWIDE FOR MEDICAL
CARE AND OTHER ISSUES. SO IN MY
MIND. I SEE MORE THIS COMING
BECAUSE THESE- PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS REALLY WERE BILL
FOR THIS. AND NOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE IN ESSENCE YOU HAVE GROWN
MEN. TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD MAN
IN THE FACILITIES WALKING
AROUND. WITH THAT YOU KNOW YOU
LOOK AT THE AGE AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW- AND IN THE
POPULATION A DJ WITH A HUNDRED
FIFTY. WAS DOWN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY SO WHEN IT SAYS IT'S
GONNA BE EQUAL I DON'T SEE IT
BEING EQUAL MONTHLY COUNTIES
AND YEAH. SOME COUNTY MAKE
CONTACT WITH OTHER COUNTY BUT-
THE END OF THE DAY. IT'S GONNA
BE DONE DIFFERENT WAYS SO I
GUESS. WHAT MY QUESTION IS DJJ
HAS MASTERED THIS OVERTIME.
THROUGH TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS.
THE COUNTIES ARE GONNA HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING DAY ONE IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. SO I SEE MORE
OF THIS AND IF ANYTHING I SEE
REGRESSION. SO HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU COUNTER THAT THERE'S- WE
WILL BE TAKING TWO STEPS BACK.
IN PURSUING THIS IN GOING
FORWARD WITH THIS. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. I GUESS IT
WOULD SAVE YOU A PART OF THIS
IS THAT THE THIS DECISION ON
THE REALIGNMENT TO COUNTIES WAS
DECIDED AT IT V. I. S. B. TWO
THREE WHICH WAS ENACTED LAST
YEAR THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT'S ALLOCATED-
THAT IS KIND OF IT. BASED ON
ASSUMPTIONS OF THE YOUTH THAT
WOULD ULTIMATELY BE A LOT REAL
LINES THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NUMBER IS REALLY THE YOUTH THAT
WOULD STILL BE ACTED JJ AT THE
TIME OF THE PLANT CLOSURE AND
SO. I WOULD SAY THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED- AS A PART OF- I SPEAK
TO THREE WHICH WAS THE AT THE
BILL ENACTED LAST YEAR TO
PREPARE PLANS- THAT. DISCUSS
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND
FACILITIES THAT THEY AND
SERVICES THAT THEY WOULD BE
OFFERING RELYING TO USE THAT
THAT IS- AS A PART OF THE
CONDITION OF FUNDING. AND
CERTAINLY THOSE PLANS WOULD
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS THAT SB TWO THREE
SPECIFIED TO BE INVOLVED IN
THAT PROCESS. AS THE GOAL AGAIN
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU DO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SERVICES
THAT WILL ENABLE THEM TO BE
MOST. SUCCESSFUL AND ULTIMATELY
A DECISION. THAT THE POLICY
HERE IS THAT- THERE'S A BELIEF
THAT YOUTH WOULD BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL BEING A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO HOME. AND THAT WAS
REALLY THE PREMISE FOR THE
REALIGNMENT LAST YEAR AND SO
HOPEFULLY BETWEEN ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT KIND OF FRAMEWORKS
AND PROCESSES THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED IN SB EIGHT TO
THREE. AND THAT THIS BILL-
ESSENTIALLY KIND OF. STRUCTURED
AROUND THE IDEA IS TO TRY TO
PROVIDE COUNTIES- SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT LEVEL OF SERVICE THIS.
TWENTY HEAR FOLKS TALK ABOUT
BEING CLOSER HOME BECAUSE WE
DON'T REALLY WALK THE WALK WHEN
IT COMES TO- THE CDC ARE FOLKS
BEING CLOSER TO HOME. SO MANY
TALK ABOUT TECHNICAL CONFORMING
CHANGES. WHAT COULD CHANGE.
THERE ARE THOSE THAT'S VERY
VAGUE. YEAH A COUPLE OF THE
EXAMPLES HAPPY TO WALK YOU
THROUGH A FEW FIRST OF ALL THE
BILL SPECIFIES THE DJJ CLOSER
DATE OF JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND SO WE HAVE TO
SUNSET VARIOUS PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD APPLY- THAT WON'T APPLY
ESSENTIALLY AFTER THAT TIME SO
THAT'S A PART OF WHAT WE REFER
TO THE TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES THERE WAS ALSO. TWENTY
NINETEEN LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED SB EIGHT TO THREE- AND
SO THERE WERE JUST AND KIND OF
CLEAN UPS WERE MAKING SURE THAT
DJ IS REFERRED TO APPROPRIATELY
OR THAT CODE SECTION
REFERENCES- ARE CORRECT. SO YOU
SEE THAT THOSE ARE I'M HAPPY TO
KIND OF I PROVIDE MORE
SPECIFICS AT YOUR OFFICE IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT THEY
REALLY ARE KIND OF TECHNICAL IN
NATURE IN THAT IT'S JUST MAKING
SURE THAT THE CODE SECTIONS
ARE. KIND OF. APPLICABLE AS
THEY SHOULD BE AND THAT THERE'S
CLARIFICATION IN THE STATUTES
AND I DJ IS IT IS REFERENCED BY
THE APPROPRIATE NAME FOR
EXAMPLE. SURE AND ALL THE POLLS
ON THIS YEAH WE'RE DOING TO THE
COUNTIES AND COUNTIES CAN
CONTACT OTHER COUNTIES. BUT AS
WE'VE SEEN WITH THE REALIGNMENT
FROM THE- JAILS. THINGS ARE
DONE IN A MYRIAD OF WAYS AND A
LOT OF PROGRAMS ARE NOT
EFFECTIVE SO. YOU KNOW IN MY
HUMBLE OPINION THIS IS. WE'RE
GONNA SEE MORE OF THAT. ARE
BEING DONE DIFFERENT NOT HAVING
AWARD WINNING THING- I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND SWITCH GEARS TO-
SB NINETY THREE. IT COOPER AT
THE DISTRICT MISMAS QUE OKAY SO
YOUR QUESTION AND THEN SURE FOR
TO GO TO SB NINETY THREE-
JENNIFER CAME WITH THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE ONE PIECE OF
CONTEXT I WANTED TO PROVIDE
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS THAT.
CURRENTLY THERE ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE ANNUALLY
THAT COULD BE SENT TO THE DJJ.
THAT COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY
KEEPING THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM SO ONLY THREE HUNDRED AND
UP POINTED THE DJJ. AND CELL
COUNTIES ALREADY HAVE. BUILT IN
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE- SB EIGHT TO
THREE HELPS TO FILL THE GAP.
FOR THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE
STILL- NEEDING SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND IT DOES ALLOW FOR
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT FINANCE HAS
MENTIONED- SO- YOU KNOW THE.
THE KIND OF D. AND THEN. OF
YOUNG PEOPLE BE SAID TO DJ-
IT'S LARGELY DUE- EMPIRE. TO
THE- HAVING BILL UP THERE COULD
PASS. IN THE LAST TEN YEARS TO
TACKLE THIS POPULATION SO THREE
HUNDRED THAT. WERE PREVIOUSLY
GOING TO DJJ WERE THE PRETTY
MUCH THE WORST THE WORST.
SEMESTER THOSE FOLKS BEING A
DJJ. THEY'RE GONNA BE THE
CALIBRATION APARTMENTS. I WOULD
SAY THAT- THE THREE HUNDRED OR
SO YOUNG PEOPLE DEPENDING ON
KIND OF WHAT. WE CHARACTERIZE
THEM AS THE HIGH NEEDS
POPULATIONS A SOME OF THEM MAY
HAVE TO MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
SOME OF THEM HAVE- OTHER KIND
OF CRIMINAL GENIC KIND OF-
ISSUES- THERE IS CAPACITY AT
THE COUNTY- AND THEN. THE
RESOURCES ARE ARE BEING
PROVIDED TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER USER
PER YEAR IS TO HELP SUPPORT-
SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMMING. WHEN YOU SEE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT GOES UP TO AGE
TWENTY FIVE CORRECT. THAT IS
THE AGE OF JURISDICTION THAT'S
CURRENTLY AT DJJ THAT WE ARE-
REPLICATING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
I THINK MOST OF US IN HERE
DON'T CONSIDER PEOPLE UNDER AGE
TWENTY FIVE IN THEIR TWENTIES
YOUNG PEOPLE AT LEAST I DON'T-
SOCIAL THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. IT GOES BACK
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT THE- DJJ HAS
AN AWARD WINNING PROGRAM.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA SEE THAT COME
OUT OF ANY COUNTY AND ALLOW
WHERE MANY COUNTY THAT'S AWARD.
WINNING PROGRAMMING DOING WITH
SOME OF IT SOME OF THE ISSUES.
WORDS MIL HEALTH OR SEXUAL
OFFENDERS- I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
OF IN IN THE STATE THAT HAVE
THAT SO. ACCESS THE HORSES LEFT
THE BARN ALREADY PURCHASED. IF
WE REALLY WANT TO REHABILITATE
PEOPLE- WE HAD A GREAT PROGRAM
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ANYMORE SO
IT'S JUST. IT'S FRUSTRATING ON
MY PART OF YOUR THE FRUSTRATION
IN MY VOICE- SO SWITCHING GEARS
TO- SB NINETY THREE IN AB
NINETY THREE. A SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL BEFORE US. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHAT THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN SB NINETY THREE. AND A
B. THREE THIRTY TO SIXTEEN FROM
LAST YEAR. WITH THE GOVERNOR
VETOED. YES I'VE HEARD THAT
QUESTION OVER TO EITHER- DANIEL
BRANDON OR DAVID FALTER TO
EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THOSE TWO BILLS. IN A DRESS OR
WHAT WHAT I'M AWARE OF IN THAT
REGARD- ALL OF THE THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN LAST YEAR PROVIDED THAT
THE EMPLOYERS WOULD BE ALL
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. THE NAME
THE NAMES OF EMPLOYEES WHO WERE
HIRED. TO OTHER ALL LAID OFF
EMPLOYEES AND- THIS NEW
PROVISION OR WOMEN H. THAT- IT
ALSO THIS BILL AS I INDICATED
BEFORE IS WHEN. MADE IT ON TO
THE COUPLE OF ITS STATE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICE ONLY THIS IS
THE SUNSETS AT THE END OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR.
IN THE ONLY EMPLOYEES WHO WERE
PROVIDED ANY OF. THE RIGHTS ARM
SLOWLY. OF ON FULL OF CO. THE
ACTION RELATED TO WITH. ARE
THOSE ONLY DIFFERENCES. COMPARE
THAT THAT IN AND FROM NINE
THREE IN THE THIRD WHICH IS THE
ONLY ONCE. I'M DANIELLE RENDON
WITH PARTNER. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- THERE ARE FEW OTHERS
AND AB I'M SORRY YEAH SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE ADDS A NEW SECTION
IN THE LABOR CODE. AND WHEREAS
PREVIOUSLY IT WAS JUST A
MODIFICATION- IN SENIORITY- IS
DEFINED IN THE SB NINETY THREE-
WHERE IT WASN'T TO FIND BEFORE.
AND SB NINETY THREE ALSO ADDS
AS MR BALZER HAD MENTIONED
EIGHTY S. SUNSET DATE OF
SEPTEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. EMPLOYERS ARE FIVE
DAYS AFTER THE JOB OFFER AND-
KNOW THAT THOSE ARE THE ONES
THAT I HAVE LISTED HERE TO
RESPOND SORRY FIVE DAYS AFTER
THE JOB OFFER TO RESPOND TO THE
EMPLOYER CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK
MORE ABOUT THE SIX MILLION
APPROPRIATED. IN S. B. NINETY
THREE. SHARES SO THIS AMOUNT-
IS THAT REFLECTS THE AMOUNTS
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. SO
INCLUDING RETALIATION COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS THE FIELD
ENFORCEMENT AND THEN ALSO. H.
INCLUDING EXPANDING- D. I. OURS
MULTI LINGUAL OUTREACH AND
THEN- I CANNOT TURN IT TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE I. R. IF HE
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO ADD ON THE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS. FUNDING WOULD BE USED.
GO AHEAD SORRY. YES UNDERSTAND
THE FUNDING WOULD BE USED FOR
OBVIOUSLY INVESTIGATORS TO
INVESTIGATE CLAIMS OF ALL
VIOLATION OF THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS SECTION ALL IS WELL AS
ATTORNEYS TO LITIGATE- ANY. I
ELECTIONS THAT ARE NOT RESOLVED
ASSIST THE OFF FIELD STAFF IN
DOING THEIR INVESTIGATIONS AND
ALSO THERE BE PROVISIONS FOR-
FOR AUDITORS IN THE CASE OF THE
CASE NEEDED. WORKED UP. HAVE WE
PREVIOUSLY VOTED ON PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR THE SAME PURPOSE.
BUT NOT FOR THIS STATE. THAT
I'M AWARE OF. THIS IS ACTUALLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE HAVE NOT PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED FUNDS TO DIR FEES BOB
PROVISIONS. BUT I'M MAYBE I'M
MISTAKEN BUT THOUGHT WE
PROVIDED SOME FUNDS LAST YEAR
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF THESE ISSUES. MIKE
MY INCORRECT. I'M DANIEL BRAND
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THERE WAS SIX MINUTES. CLEATED
IN ABOUT BELIEVE IT WAS S. B.
ONE FIFTEEN HOWEVER THOSE
RESOURCES WERE NOT SPECIFIC TO
THIS TYPE OF WORK WITH- AND
SPECIFIC TO HOSPITALITY WORKERS
BUT HIS ANY OF THAT MONEY BEING
USED TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
THOUGH I MEAN WE'RE TALKING SIX
MILLION. AND LAST BUDGET YEAR
AND SIX MILLION THIS YEAR SO A
TOTAL OF TWELVE MILLION THERE
HAS TO BE SOME CROSS
POLLINATION IN THAT. MISTER
WALTER I'M NOT SURE IF YOU CAN
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE- FUNDING
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED
FOR DIFFERENT ENFORCEMENT AND
IF THAT HAS BEEN UTILIZED. IF
THAT'S BEEN COMPLETELY
ALLOCATED- AT THIS POINT. I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT ASPECT
OF THE OF THE BILL ON SO I
WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF. FINANCE ON THAT.
SO WHAT WILL HAVE TO GET SOME
OF THE OTHER DETAILS FOR YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SURE THAT THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL. THE
METRO TO MIAMI MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS THAT MONEY WAS.
APPROPRIATED FOR. THE
PARTICULAR FOR WORKING
HOSPITALITY WORKERS
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
ACCOMPANYING LEGISLATION THAT
DID NOT GET SIGNED BECAUSE IT
WASN'T POLICY AGREEMENT SO
SINCE THERE WAS A SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING BUT NOT-
ADEQUATE POLICY AGREEMENT THIS
THIS REFLECTS THROUGH THE
POLICY AGREEMENT. ON HOW TO
SPEND THE SIX MILLION THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE FOR THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AS WELL AS THE MUD THE
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION WHICH IS
IN THIS BILL. OKAY BUT I'M I'M
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH OF LAST YEAR'S SIX MILLION
TOUCH THIS ISSUE. FOR ME I'M
I'M I'VE I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT A
PORTION OF IT DID. WAS TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. WHAT IS A LOT OF MY
AND MY UNDERSTANDING WAS. LAST
YEAR IT WAS A VERY ODD
SITUATION WHERE THE MONEY GOT
IN THE BUDGET. BUT THERE WAS.
NO POLICY DIRECTION AND SO
THAT'S I THINK THAT'S REALLY
WHY WE'RE HAVING THIS.
CLARIFICATION HERE IN THIS N
THIS BUDGET IN THIS BUDGET BILL
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE HE WAS- IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT NEEDED TO BE
FINISHED BUT NEVER GOT FINISHED
DURING THE LAST BUDGET SURE SO
WHAT SO WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT
MONEY EVEN. IF THE MONEY STILL
THE BUDGET THE SIX MORE FROM
LAST YEAR YES. YES ALL WAS
NEVER SPENT. THAT'S I MEAN I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS BETTER NOT
THAT IT WASN'T IT WAS
APPROPRIATE IN THE BUDGET SO
WAS IT SPEND. ROUGHLY MISTER
COOPER MR TANG- I NEED TO FIND
CLARIFICATION ON THAT SO I WILL
DO THAT DURING THIS HEARING AND
GET BACK TO YOU. SO I WOULD ASK
IF IT WASN'T MEANT. WHERE WE
SPENDING IT. THIS YEAR SO I
THINK THAT'S FAIR. SO THE MONEY
WAS DEFINITELY APPROPRIATE
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I COULD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
RAMOS A NUMBER GOING TO GO TO
MISTER BLOOM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- IN MY FIRST- BUT
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS WILL BE
ON S. B. EIGHTY FIVE WITH THE
WHILE FACT FIRE EARLY ACTION
PROPOSALS- THIS BILL- DISPERSES
IMPORTANT RESOURCES ACROSS THE
STATE TO ENSURE WE ARE PREPARED
FOR THE UPCOMING FIRE SEASON I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR PUTTING-
THE TWENTY TWO MILLION DIRECTLY
INTO HOME HARDENING ASSISTANCE.
AND ALSO HIGHLIGHTING- TO
CALIFORNIA FOR TRAVELING GAUGE
MINT- AND THE STEPS ARE NEEDED
AND VITAL TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MY
QUESTION ALSO IS AROUND THE
STAFFING ELEMENT FOR OUR- STATE
FIREFIGHTERS CAL FIGHTER IN THE
FIRES THAT WE KNOW ARE COMING I
KNOW LAST YEAR WE TALKED ABOUT-
MAKING SURE THAT STAFFING WAS
THERE AND WE SEE THE FIRES COME
OUR WAY. AND THERE WAS FAR MORE
ON OUTSIDE- FIREFIGHTERS COMING
IN TO HELP WITH THE FIRES ARE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I JUST WNTED TO- ASK DOES. ANY
OF THIS MONEY START TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT STAFF- ISSUES THAT
WE ARE FOR HERE THE STATE. WITH
OUR- CALIFORNIA FIRE HERE IN A
OWN STAY. CUSTOMER AT
ALTERNATIVE TO MY CAR STEPHEN.
MORNING BASS WITH APARTMENT. SO
THE FUNDING IN THIS PARTICULAR
PACKAGE YOU CAN SEE RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NOT GO TOWARDS
STAFFING- FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION
ACTIVITIES- THAT. THIS IS
FOCUSED ON FIRE PREVENTION AND
FOREST RESILIENCE. THE STATE
HAS INVESTED. MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN RECENT YEARS TO
EXPAND THE FIRE SUPPRESSION
RESOURCES OF THE STATE AND WHAT
WE RECOGNIZED IS THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE. I'M A CO PARTNER
INVESTMENT IN FIRE PREVENTION
AND FOREST RESILIENCE THERE
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE CAN.
JUST WITH FIRE SUPPRESSION AND
BREAK THE CYCLE OF CATASTROPHIC
FIRE THAT WE'VE HAD THE SEWER
THIS THIS IS FOCUSED ON MAKING
STRATEGIC. INVESTMENTS IN A
SHOVEL READY NEAR TERM
PROJECTS. THAT CAN GIVE REAL
FIRE PREVENTION AND REAL FORCE
RESILIENCE BENEFITS- AND THE
FIRE SUPPRESSION SIDE WHAT WHAT
HAS HAPPENED RECENTLY AS WE DID
DO AN AUGMENTATION. TO THE
EMERGENCY FUND THAT PROVIDED-
ABOUT EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR CAL FIRE TO BRING
IN SEASONAL STAFFING EARLY AND
GET A BETTER PREPARED FOR THE
FIRE SEASON THAT'S ALREADY UPON
US- IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A PROPOSALS
THAT HELP- WITH ADDITIONAL
CREWS AND RESOURCES IN THAT IN
THAT NATURE SO. IT'S NOT THAT
WE'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT FIRE
SUPPRESSION RUN AROUND DOING
THINGS ON IT BUT THIS
PARTICULAR PACKAGE IS FOCUSED
ON FIRE PREVENTION. AND FOREST
RESILIENCE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION BUT IT BEGS THE
QUESTION OF IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FIRE PREVENTION AND WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE FIRE
SUPPRESSION KEEPING A BALANCE.
THAT THERE HAS TO BE THE TRUE
DISCUSSION OF BOTH OF THEM ARE
MOVING FORWARD WITH IN THE
LEGISLATURE WITHIN THE BUDGET
BUDGET CYCLE- MOVING FORWARD SO
HOPEFULLY WE WILL SEE THAT IN
FUTURE BUDGET ITEMS. THE STARS
TO ADDRESS THE STAFFING IN THE
SAFETY OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
DO HAVE- OTHER QUESTIONS ON S.
B. NINETY THREE- IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR. ON SB NINETY
THREE. IT TALKS ABOUT HOW-
BUSINESSES- RIGHT ARE ABLE TO-
THEY HAVE FIVE BUSINESS DAYS.
TO OFFER TO AN EMPLOYEE- TO
COME BACK TO WORK IN THE
EMPLOYEE HAS FIVE BUSINESS DAYS
TO RESPOND. IS THAT CORRECT IN
MY READING THAT CORRECTLY.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY AND THEN
THE NEXT THE QUESTION IS THEN
YOU HAVE THIRTY DAYS- TO
RESPOND AS TO WHY- AN EMPLOYER
HAS NOT HIRED SOMEBODY BACK
UNDER THE COVERT. PARAMETERS
ARE SET OUT IN THIS BILL MY
QUESTION IS DO BOTH OF THOSE
COMPONENTS GOAL WITH ONE
ANOTHER MEANING THAT OF I HAVE
AN EMPLOYEE AND I OFFER THEM
BACK THEIR JOB. THEY TAKE IT
THAT'S GREAT BUT IF THEY REFUSE
DO I STILL HAVE TWO THEN
HIGHLIGHT AND GIVE THE REASONS
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF WHY I
DIDN'T HIRE THEM. I'M GONNA TRY
TO PATCH INTO MY COLLEAGUES
FROM DR FOR SPECIFIC THANK YOU.
YEAH IT DOES I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WE WOULD ENFORCE IT. WHAT
THEY END UP. TO LIVE. HIM THERE
PLAYER IN MEETING THE ROB
CATION. BY ALL. MAKING FINDING
IT OUT ENQUIRING WHETHER THE
EMPLOYEE IT READY TO ACCEPT THE
JOB WHEN THE EMPLOYEE INDICATES
THAT THEY DO NOT WANT TO ACCEPT
THE REASON TO ENFORCE
PROVISIONS REQUIRED REASONS
LATER ON. SO THEN- IT WAS
BREAKING UP A LITTLE BIT MISTER
CHAIR SO IT'S CLEAR THAT IF AN
EMPLOYER- OFFERS AN EMPLOYEE TO
HIRE THEM BACK UNDER THESE
PARAMETERS AND THE EMPLOYEE HAS
UP TO FIVE BUSINESS DAYS TO
EITHER ACCEPT OR DENY THAT THAT
OFFER IF THEY DENY IT WE'RE
SAYING THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
EMPLOYER DOES NOT HAVE
OBLIGATIONS TO STATE WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS WHY THEY DID NOT
HIRE THE INDIVIDUAL BACK. YEAH
IN MY RESPONSE TO IT THAT THE
STATE WOULD HAVE EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION OVER ENFORCEMENT
OF THAT I CAN'T SEE US. IN
FORCING IN A IN A MANNER WHICH
ALL MAKES NO SENSE SUCH AS
YOU'RE DESCRIBING ON IF THE
EMPLOYEES IN. THE CASE THAT
THEY DO NOT WANT THE JOB. THEN
THE EMPLOYER MOVES ON TO THE
NEXT HIGHER SINGLE PERSON ON
THE LIST. THANK YOU FOR THAT
NUMBER I JUST WANNA A THEN-
CLARIFY AGAIN. THAT IN THIS- SB
NINETY THREE THE ONE IN FRONT
OF US NOW THERE DOES NOT HAVE.
A PRIVATE RIGHT TO ACTION
COMPONENT IN IT. CORRECT AND
THEN JUST MIGHT MY LAST
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR IS THE
REASONING FOR CHOOSING A SUNSET
DATE- IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR HOW DO WE REACH
THAT DATE THAT SOME FAR IN MY
OPINION KIND OF FAR OUT THERE
STRETCHING SO HOW DO WE RESET
THERE HAS TO BE SOME LOGIC OR
SOME SOME PREMISE AS TO HOW WE
GOT TO THAT DATE. I THINK THAT
IT PROVIDES- TIME FOR THE
INDUSTRY TO RECOVER AND TRUMP
IT'S OUR EMPLOYEES THE
OPPORTUNITY WHO HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF IN THIS IN THESE AND IN
THIS INDUSTRY. THE ABILITY TO-
RECOVER AS WELL AS THAT AS THE
INDUSTRY RECOVERED THAT THOSE
EMPLOYEES ARE THEN OFFERED-
POSITIONS BACK IN THEIR- PLACE
OF WORK. IN THE DOCUMENTATION
OF AND MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
BILL- THAT WE'VE READ SB NINETY
THREE THAT IT ONLY PERTAINS TO
THOSE THAT WERE AFFECTED
THROUGH COVERT NINETEEN. THAT'S
RIGHT THE- EMERGENCY NEEDS TO
BE CORPORATE- RELATED I THINK
THE PRIOR VERSION WAS OPEN TO
OTHER TYPES OF EMERGENCIES- BUT
THIS IS A LAYOFF DUE TO
SPECIFIC FACTORS RELATED TO
COVER NINETEEN. IN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PROVING THAT
AN EMPLOYEE WAS LAID OFF BASED
ON COVERT NINETEEN. IS WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY THE EMPLOYEE OR
THE EMPLOYER- I'M NOT TRYNA
QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DR FOR SPECIFICS. YES SO IF IT
THE EMPLOYEE WAS NOT LAID OFF
OLD TO COATED THEN THAT WOULD
BE THE- EMPLOYER HERE SAID IN.
RELATION SO. THE BURDEN WOULD
BE TOO EMPLOYER TO. MAKE THEIR
TROUBLING THIS CALDERON WHAT
THE REASON WAS HELLO MISTER
WALTER WHAT WILL YOU TURN OFF
YOUR CAPS PERHAPS THE INTERNET
WILL BE YES. WATER TO TRY
TURNING OFF YOUR CAMERA BECAUSE
IT'S DIFFICULT TO HEAR YOU
BECAUSE YOUR CONNECTION IS POOR.
I JUST. CLICK SO. GET OKAY IT'S
THE WORST YOU CAN TERM DR
DEMOCRATS. YEAH THAT THE THAT
DIDN'T WORK. MR BALTER WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND TURN BACK TO
CAMERA BUT FOR SOME REASON IT
DID YOUR INTERNET CONNECTION IS
POOR FOR SOME REASON. NOT NOT
NOT NOT. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY CAN YOU
PLEASE. REPEAT THE LAST
QUESTION TO GET. SO ARM. WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF WHO
IDENTIFIES AN EMPLOYEE UNDER
THE CLOVER NINETEEN TO GET TO
THAT AT SUNSET DATA TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR IS THE VERY END OF
THAT ON THE EMPLOYEE OR THE
EMPLOYER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ACTUALLY UNDER THE SCOPE OF
IT NINETEEN- SECTION HERE AND
SB NINETY THREE AND MISTER
CHAIR IT'S WITH JENNA- BACKING
FOR FLUID SO MAYBE THERE COULD
BE A EMAIL TO MY OFFICE ON
CLARIFYING SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS ALSO. NORMALLY THE
EMPLOYER HAS THE- BURDEN OF.
MAKING D. R. THE INITIAL
STATEMENT AS TO THE REASONS WHY
THE EMPLOYEE WHILE I SLOW
PLAYED ALL OF. AND INSURE THAT
WOULD BE. THE FIRST ALL. I'M
SITUATION AT ALL TO MIDDLE.
LAKE IF THERE'S A DISPUTE IS
GOING TO BE A. OUR INSURANCE
THAT THE EMPLOYEE. YEAH I'M-
HERE WOMAN TARA MACINNES
SEARCHING WELL I'LL MAKE SURE
TO GET THAT RESPONSE IN WRITING
AND SEND IT TO YOU AS WELL TO
CLARIFY FURTHER WHO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY. THANK YOU HAVE
MISTER BALTAR'S CONNECTIONS
VERY POOR SO- IF YOU HAVE
ANOTHER IF YOU COULD HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE ANSWER HIS HIS
QUESTIONS THAT BE APPROPRIATE
BUT- I THINK HAVING MR BALTER
ASK ANY ANSWER ANY MORE
QUESTIONS THAT'S NOT VERY
HELPFUL FOR THE HEARING.
MYSTERON US THANK THANK YOU FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS I DO STILL
UNDERSTAND THAT- THE DIFFERENCE
IN SOME OF THESE BILLS TO- THAT
IT ONLY APPLIES TO WORKERS LAID
OFF DURING COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- AND HAS NO EMPLOYEE
RETENTION REQUIREMENTS ALSO ON
THESE. SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THOSE- ANSWERS TO OUR
QUESTIONS AND. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU GONNA
MISS BLOOM AND MISTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE-
COMMENTS NOT QUESTIONS WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR ME TO ADD THOSE
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND LET ME BEGIN- I. BY SAYING
OUT I WANT TO ADDRESS-
SPECIFICALLY SB EIGHTY FIVE. A
SINCE I BECAME INTIMATELY
FAMILIAR WITH- WITH WITH THAT-
AT THE CONTENTS OF THAT BUILDER
IN THE COURSE OF NEGOTIATING-
THE PACKAGE. AND I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN THE ASSEMBLY WORKING
GROUP. BUT MEMBERS WHO WERE AT
THREE OF US. JIM WOOD AND LAURA
FRIEDMAN OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
STAFF THE SPEAKERS STAFF MY
SENATE COUNTERPART SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI THE GOVERNOR.
AND HIS STAFF. OF THIS TRULY IS
A LANDMARK ACCOMPLISHMENT IN MY
OPINION AND WHY DO I SAY THAT
WELL. THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE HAVE FOCUSED- THIS
KIND OF MONEY ON PREVENTION
EFFORTS- AND THE- THAT THE
BILL'S CALLED WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCY BUT WE REALLY
SHOULD THINK OF THIS. AS
PREDOMINATELY PREVENTION MONEY-
LET ME GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF- WHY
THAT THE MAGNITUDE OF- OF THIS
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING SPENT
ON- EFFORTS THAT ARE SIMILAR TO
WHAT IS AND- S. B. EIGHTY FIVE.
THIS YEAR IT'S FIVE HUNDRED AND
IT'LL BE FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION AND THAT'S
JUST THE EARLY ACTION PART-
THAT IS ALMOST SEVEN FOLD WHAT
WE SPENT IN THAT WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING IN THE CURRENT YEAR-
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS ALREADY
PROPOSED CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT WE WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
IN THE JUNE BUDGET. AND ADD TO
OUR- MOLD UP MUCH IN THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE- MOLDED THE EARLY
ACTION PLAN BUT THAT EARLY
ACTION PIECES THE OTHER THING
THAT MAKES THIS SO IMPORTANT-
WE ARE ALLOCATING MONEY TODAY.
TO AGENCIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE AS WE SPEAK PLANNING
HOW TO ROLL OUT THESE EFFORTS-
IN ADVANCE AND AS FIRE SEASON
IS BEGINNING. OF THAT'S NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE AND IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT GIVEN- A
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT WILDFIRE IN
THE STATE- IT'S OUR IT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED OVER AND OVER AGAIN-
JUST HOW INTENSE. LAST YEAR'S
FIRE SEASON WAS BUT LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT- THE SEVERAL YEARS
LEADING UP TO LAST YEAR EACH OF
THOSE SEASONS WAS A RECORD
BREAKING SEASON IT'S BEEN WORSE
AND WORSE AND WORSE. AND SO-
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A MORE
IMPORTANT TIME FOR US TO BEGIN
DOING THIS WORK WE WILL NOT.
LET ME REPEAT WE WILL NOT DO
ALL THE PREVENTION WORK WE NEED
TO DO- WITH FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS OR
WITH A BILLION DOLLARS. THIS
NEEDS TO BE THOUGHT OF AS THE
BEGINNING OF AN ON GOING EFFORT
AND TO GIVE YOU AGAIN AN IDEA
THE ORDER OF MAGNITUDE- WE
SPEND. IN THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
WE SPENT ABOUT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS. FIGHTING FIRES DURING
THAT SUPPRESSION WORK- THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT WE TAKE NOTHING
AWAY FROM THAT- BY DOING THE
PREVENTION WORK BUT HOPEFULLY
BY SPENDING MONEY ON
PREVENTION. WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE. THE NUMBER OF FIRES
THERE WERE NINETY FOUR HUNDRED
LAST YEAR. AT NOT ONLY THE
NUMBER OF FIRES BUT THE EXTENT-
TO WHICH THEY BURN. NOT A ROUTE
A RECENT FEEL STUDY SHOWED
THAT- CHAPARRAL WITH- HAS
RECORD LOW MOISTURE VALUES IN
APRIL AND LITTLE TO NO GROUP.
NO GROWTH- WHEN THEY SHOULD BE
BLOOMING RIGHT NOW. CHAPARRAL
OR FLAMMABLE SHRUBS THERE FOUND
ALL OVER THE STATE BUT THEY'RE
PARTICULARLY PREVALENT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WITH.
RECORD LOW RANGE AND RECORD
HEAT IT'S EXPECTED THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WILDFIRE
SEASON COULD BE SEVERE- AGAIN
SOMETHING THAT'S ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL THAT IS NOVEL AND
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IS THAT WE
RECOGNIZE. IN THE BUDGET ACTION
THE DIFFERENCES IN TERRAIN AND
VEGETATION AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE WITH PREVENTION OF
SPECIFIC TO DIFFERENT REGIONS
OF THE STATE. OF. M. DOUG- SO
AGAIN ANOTHER REASON WHY THIS
IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
STATE'S WILDFIRES SOURCES ARE
AS DIVERSE AS THE STATE ITSELF.
THE TO ANSWER- A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER THE QUESTION FROM- OUR
OUR COLLEAGUE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE- WE ARE FINDING TWELVE
NEW CRUISE THROUGH THE- THE E.
FUND THERE'S ALSO FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE EARLY
BUDGET ACTION FOR HAND CREWS.
PEOPLE WHO WILL GO OUT AND
ACTUALLY DO THIS VEGETATION
WORK WITH THEIR HANDS AND HAND
TOOLS- IN A YEAR WHERE WE ARE
COMING OFF OF OUR MOST DEADLY
FIRE SEASON FACED WITH DROUGHT
LIKE CONDITIONS RECORD LOW
RAINFALL RECORD HIGH
TEMPERATURES PLANTS AND TREES
AROUND THE STATE ARE EXTREMELY
STRESSED RIGHT NOW RESULTING IN
DRIER AND MORE DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS EARLIER THAN THE
STATE HAS EVER SEEN THIS
FUNDING COULD NOT COME AT A
MORE CRUCIAL TIME AND I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS LIFESAVING.
EARLY BUDGET ACTION. THANK YOU
MISTER WE'RE GOING TO GO TO-
MISTER JONES SAWYER IN THE
MIDST RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- MY COMMENT IS REALLY ON
SB NINETY TWO AND HOPEFULLY TO
SET SOME. SOME HOPEFULLY SOME
GUIDELINES AND SOME HELP NOT
ONLY FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT FOR THIS BODY OF MANY OF US
HERE. ALL WERE NOT HERE WHEN IT
AB ONE OH NINE REALIGNMENT WAS
VOTED IN. BUT WHEN WE GOT
ELECTED WE HEARD OF ALL THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES THAT
HAPPENED IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT.
AND AS I SAID SINCE I'VE GOTTEN
HERE. IT'S NEVER REALLY
LEGISLATION THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS IMPLEMENTATION. AND
WHAT IS WHAT IS PROBLEMATIC
RIGHT NOW IS WE DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG THIS WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
AT THE LOWER LEVELS- WHETHER
IT'S THREE HUNDRED NINETY NINE
GOING DOWNWARD RIGHT NOT
EXISTING STRUCTURES THERE- WE
NEED MORE. SPECIFICITY ON HOW
THIS WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED AND I
THINK WHICH YOU WHICH YOU'RE
FEELING NOT ONLY FROM PROBATION
BUT YOU SHOULD BE FEELING SOME
THANKS FROM THE COMMUNITY
GROUPS THAT. WERE SOME SOME
COUNTY OFFICES ARE PLANNING TO
SEND THEM OUT TO HELP WITH
THAT- WE NOT ONLY NEED TO KNOW
WHAT WHAT THAT IS. BUT ALSO
THEY HAVE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT A LOT OF OUR BILLS THAT WE
DO AND- I LOVE WHAT WE DO UP
HERE. BUT WE DON'T PUT ENOUGH.
RESOURCES MONEY. AND JUST
REALLY LAYING OUT HOW SOMETHING
WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED ONCE WE
MAKE A DECISION. AND SO DID FOR
EXAMPLE THE OFFICE OF USE AND
COMMITTEE RESTORATION AND
BUDGET SUB FIVE. OF THERE WAS A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT IT IN
THE COMMITTED I SIT ON. UNDER A
LOT OF MEMBERS THAT THEIR ON-
BUT TO SOME FIVE THE FELT THAT
THE OFFICE MAY NOT HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
THIS MAMMOTH UNDERTAKING. AND
SO- MY SUGGESTION. AND I HELLO
I'M WORKING WITH OTHERS TO TRY
TO COME UP WITH SOME. SOME
SPECIFIC GUIDELINES ON HOW THIS
WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED. WITHOUT
INTERFERING TOO MUCH WITH THE
LOCAL AUTHORITY BUT MAKING SURE
THAT THE LOCAL AUTHORITY THEN
COME BACK TO A YEAR FROM NOW.
AND SAY THAT THEY DO THEY WERE
UNDER RESOURCE UNDER FUNDED OR
THEY DIDN'T GET ENOUGH
DIRECTION. FROM THIS BODY ON
HOW TO IMPLEMENT THE- THE DJJ
OF REALIGNMENT AND SO- WE NEED
TO GET THIS DONE AND WE NEED TO
GET SOME ANSWERS FOR REALLY
QUICKLY. I THINK YOU CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED BEFORE WE BUT NOT
THE BUDGET. BUT IT IS VITALLY
VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT ALL
SIDES SIT DOWN AND HAVE A REAL
TALK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THIS
SUCCESSFUL. THANK THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO- THIS RUBIO THE
DOCTOR REMEMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ON SO I JUST WANT
TO FOLLOW UP HAS A QUESTION
ABOUT THE SIX MILLION DOLLARS
BEEN SPENT CAN YOU TALK. A HAS
NOT BEEN ANSWERED YET. DO YOU
HAVE THE INFORMATION YET. I
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE'RE STILL LOOKING FOR
THE ACTUAL AMOUNT THAT REMAINS
BUT I WANTED TO CLARIFY AND
CONFIRM THAT SB ONE HUNDRED ONE
ONE FIVE FROM LAST AUGUST DID
APPROPRIATE SIX MILLION FOR DIR
TO ENFORCE BROADLY ANTI
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS
EMPLOYMENT MATTERS RELATED TO
EMPLOYERS RE OPENING OR
RESUMPTION OF BUSINESS
OPERATIONS DURING OR AFTER THE
CODE NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY. AS WELL AS WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY PRODUK
PROTECTIONS- THIS COULD HAVE
INCLUDED- ENFORCEMENT OF
PROTECTIONS TO ASSIST
HOSPITALITY WORKERS IN
RETURNING TO WORK ON BUT WAS
NOT SOLELY FOR THAT PURPOSE AND
SO- MY COMMENT EARLIER ABOUT
THE SIX MILLION BEING FOR
RECALL FOR HOSPITALITY WORKERS-
WAS CORRECT IN THAT THE SIX
MILLION WAS FOR SOMETHING
BROADER- THIS WOULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO DIR FOR MEANT FOR-%
RIGHT TO RETURN TO WORK- BUT
STILL. I WOULD STILL GET THAT
NUMBER FOR YOU- BUT THAT'S A
CONFIRMATION OF THE SIX MILLION
ALLOCATION THAT WITH MORE
BROADLY- PROVIDED TO D. ACT WAS
PROVIDED FOR THE AYE OFFER
BROAD. ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU
BYE I'M ARE THE QUESTION OF THE
WEEK THEY NOT TOLD THAT THIS
BILL WAS IMPORTANT TODAY
BECAUSE WE SPENT WE HAVE THE
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT
THERE WAS NO AGREEMENT ON
POLICY YOU'RE CONTRADICTING
THAT YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT
THAT MONEY WAS NOT SPECIFICALLY
FOR THAT AND IF THAT'S THE
CASE. THEN WHY THE RUSH ON
THIS- BILL IF THAT IS NOT THE
CASE- THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO- IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION. AND
WERE EXPECTED TO VOTE ON IT
TODAY THEN THAT MEANS THAT EVEN
IF YOU IF THE- BUDGET COMMITTEE
DOESN'T HAVE THE PER THE
CORRECT ANSWER IS HOW ARE WE
EXPECTED TO VET. BILLS BEFORE
ONE PM TO BE VOTED ON AT THE
ARE BUDGET COMMITTEE DOESN'T
HAVE THOSE ANSWERS. THAT'S
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO THERE WAS
A STATEMENT MADE. EARLIER THAT
THIS BILL CHANGES THE LABOR
CODE- AND- FOR THE QUESTION IS
IF IT CHANGES THE LABOR CODE
DOES THAT EXPIRE. IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AS WELL AS WHAT
YOU'RE EXPECTING TO. TO YOU
TOLD US RIGHT NOW AT THIS BILL
EXPIRING TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
DALY BY MICHELLE R. YES YOU'RE
ACTUALLY CORRECT I WILL GET YOU
GET THAT ANSWER IN REGARDS TO
SIX MILLION I JUST DON'T WANT
TO PROVIDE- AN INCORRECT ANSWER
AND I WILL GET BACK TO YOU-
BEFORE. ONE O'CLOCK. BUT THAT'S
THE POINT TO THE IS THAT IF
YOU'RE HAVING TO SCRAMBLE TO
GET THAT INFORMATION THE REASON
THAT WE'RE HERE IS. I EXPECTED
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO BE
PREPARED IF YOU THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES NOT PREPARED HOW DO
WE EXPECT ALL OF US. TO BE ABLE
TO GET THESE BILLS IF OUR OWN
BUDGET COMMITTEE IS NOT
PREPARED TO HAVE THOSE ANSWERS.
AND AGAIN THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE LABOR CODE IS BACK GOING TO
EXPIRE ALSO SENSITIVE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. BUT LABOR
CODE CHAIN. THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL- IN REGARDS TO THE RE
HIRE WILL EXPIRE AT THE END-
AND I AM NOT SURE IF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE I. R. IS
ABLE TO RESPOND TO THAT EITHER-
VIET VIA EMAIL- WHICH IS ONE
WAY THAT WE CAN COMMUNICATE
AND- HE WAS HAVING
DIFFICULTIES- BUT- THE QUESTION
WAS IN REGARDS TO WHETHER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE LABOR CODE
WOULD EXPIRE WITH THE SUNSET
DATE. AM I WAITING FOR ARE WE
WAITING FOR AN ANSWER FOR THAT.
YES I AM. I THINK THERE'S A
COMMUNICATION INTERNET ISSUES
SO I'M I'M WAITING FOR A
RESPONSE. OKAY WELL I WILL
SHARE THAT WITH YOU AS SOON AS
I GET IT. AND SO OKAY SO THEN
I'LL FOLLOW UP AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL-
BECAUSE OF THE COLDA PANDEMIC
WE'VE BEEN VOTING ON BILLS. ARE
THE LAST MONTH- LAST YEAR THAT
WERE ALL COVERT RELATED AND
MOST OF THEM HAVE EXPIRATION
DATES OF ADS. BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR SOME OF THEM
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS ONE IS
STILL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN FOR
USING COVERT AS AN EXCUSE- FOR
THIS BY THE BILL TO BE INSERTED
TODAY. IF IT'S ABOUT KOBE I
WOULD EXPECT I WOULD HOPE THAT
ALL OF THE OTHER BILLS THAT WE
PASSED SO FAR THAT HAVE BEEN
COVERED RELATED TO HAVE
EXPIRATION DATES. OF AT LEAST
THAT SOMETIME THIS YEAR AND
THIS ONE IS NOT UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR SO GOES BACK TO THE
QUESTION AGAIN ABOUT IS THIS
THE PROPER- WAY TO IMPLEMENT
THIS KIND OF POLICY IF THIS
EXPLORATION. IS NOT TILL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THEN I THINK WE
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO GET IT
THROUGH THE REGULAR PROCESS
IT'S FRUSTRATING TO ME THAT THE
BILLS THAT ARE VERY DIFFICULT
ARE PUT INTO THE BUDGET PROCESS
WITH TWO DAYS OF NOTICE TO US.
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO
EITHER GET THE BUILDING CLEARLY
YOU DON'T HAVE THE TIME EITHER
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWERS RIGHT NOW- FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO TALK TO THE OUR
CONSTITUENTS THE ONES THAT WE
HAVE TRANSFERRED TO LIVE. AND
THEN TO THE STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE
THAT WOULD BE FOR DOING THE
BEST- POLICY. CHANGES FOR OUR
STATE THAT'S WHY I THOUGHT THAT
THE POLL COMMITTEES A- FOR IT
SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT RE.
PUTTING A BILL OUT ON AGAIN
DOESN'T GIVE US ANY TIME AND IT
DOESN'T GIVE YOU ANY TIME
EITHER TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER A
QUESTION SO- I JUST. IT'S
FRUSTRATING OBVIOUSLY THAT WERE
BEING PUT IN THE POSITION WHERE
WE HAVE TO ANSWER TO OUR OWN
CONSTITUENTS WITH LITTLE OR NO
INFORMATION AND AGAIN WHEN I
ASK THE QUESTIONS OF THE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE I DON'T HAVE THOSE
ANSWERS SO IF YOU'RE NOT FOR.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT A TO BE PRE.
TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER TO OUR
SINCE THE- NOT ALL OF THE
DISTRICTS ARE THE SAME. AND SO
I WOULD LIKE THAT ANSWER AS TO
WHAT IF ANY OF THE MONEY HAS
BEEN SPENT. AND IF SO. IF WE
DON'T HAVE GUIDANCE THAT I WAS
TOLD THAT THAT WAS THE REASON
WE'RE DOING THIS BILL IS FOR
GUIDANCE FOR THOSE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. THEN HOW DO WE SPEND
THAT MONEY WITHOUT ANY GUIDANCE
WHAT FOR THE- ADDITIONAL
QUESTION IS. IF WE SPENT MONEY
WHAT DID WE SPEND IT ON AND WAS
IT RELATED TO- SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL THAT WE'RE- BEING
ASKED TO- LOOK AT TODAY.
SERVICES TAKE A STAB AT THIS AS
WELL. THIS REVIEW SO I THINK
YOUR- YOUR- YOUR FRUSTRATION IS
A VERY VALID. ON AGAIN THIS IS.
MONEY THAT WAS APPROPRIATED IN
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR ALTHOUGH
IS FOR A BROADER PURPOSE. WE
FELT THAT THIS IS A VERY NARROW
SET OF WORKERS THESE ARE GET
HOSPITALITY WORKERS- WE THOUGHT
GIVEN HOW HARD HIT THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY. THE LAWS
OF THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE- TIME
TO CLARIFY AGAIN. HI ALL SOME
OF THE SIX BILLION DOLLARS AS
OF THE READY APPROPRIATE IN THE
BUDGET COULD BE USED IN AGAIN.
WE APPROPRIATED AN ADDITIONAL
SIX. MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
SPECIFICALLY HOSPITALITY
WORKERS- BUT MR TANK ABOUT THE
QUESTIONS THAT. I ASKED YOU
DIRECTLY OVER THE WEEKEND AND
THAT'S THE SPECIFICALLY YOU
ANSWERED. THAT THIS WAS BECAUSE
OF THE SIX MILLION DOLLARS LAST
YEAR THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING THAT
QUESTION A LOT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT IT'S NOT. THAT'S NOT WHAT
I SAID AS I SAID I HAVE THE
TEXTURE HERE MISTER KING. THE
ICE I SAID. IT IS PART OF THE
SIX MILLION. I THOUGHT MISTER
KING I THAT'S WHY I ASKED OVER
THE WEEKEND AND YOU SAID
SPECIFICALLY THE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR PARTS ONE DOLLAR IS LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET BUT WAS NOT ABLE
TO REACH AGREEMENT ON THE
POLICY. AFTER FURTHER
DISCUSSION THIS YEAR WE WERE
ABLE TO FIND AGREEMENT WITH THE
SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR THAT
TELLS ME ON THE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR THE ORIGINAL SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. YOU DIDN'T SAY GOING
FORWARD. RIGHT SO THERE'S A
THERE'S ANOTHER SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN HERE AS WELL IN
ADDITION FOR MORE ENFORCEMENT.
AND AGAIN I THINK THIS IS A
VERY NARROW SET OF FOLKS FOR
THE UNDERSTAND THAT MISTER KING
BUT THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO BE
PROACTIVE AND TEXT YOU OVER THE
WEEKEND FOR THAT I DIDN'T HAVE
TO HAVE THIS DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR ANDERSON OVER. THE
DIFFERENCES AND WHEN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS NOT PREPARED THEN
THAT'S MORE FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
NOW I'M EXPECTED TO ANSWER TO
MY CONSTITUENTS AND I CAN'T
EVEN GET STRAIGHT ANSWERS FROM
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE ABOUT WHAT
WE DID WITH THE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. OKAY WELL I FIGURED I-
I THINK I'LL GIVE YOU AN ANSWER
I DON'T KNOW. THE ANSWER MAY
NOT. MEET YOUR EXPECTATIONS BUT
AGAIN THAT'S BUT THAT'S OUR
ANSWER. OKAY LET'S GO TO- IF
YOU'RE DONE THIS REVIEW THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO DOCTOR REGULAR
AND INTO MR GALLAGHER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M GOING TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS TODAY ON S.
B. EIGHTY FIVE THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AND FOLLOW UP WITH WHERE
OUR SUB THREE CHAIR SPOKE
ABOUT. THE INVESTMENTS IN
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCY.
WHILE I AM PLEASED TO SEE THE
BROAD INVESTMENT THAT WE ARE
MAKING IN EFFECTIVE LAND
MANAGEMENT I AM CONCERNED WITH
THE A MISSION OF FUNDING FOR
ALL CONSERVANCIES TO BE ABLE TO
PERFORM THE FIRE PREVENTION.
AND FUEL MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES.
SPECIFICALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHY THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY WAS OMITTED DESPITE
ITS PROXIMITY AN ONGOING FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES. GOOD
MORNING STEVEN BENSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT'S
SORT OUR- FOCUS WITH THE
CONSERVANCY'S WAS ON-
DEMONSTRATED PROJECTS THAT ARE
SHOVEL READY AND CAN OUR NEAR
TERM- FIRE PREVENTION AND
FOREST RESILIENCE BENEFITS. AND
SO WE HAVE FOCUSED DOLLARS IN A
FEW CONSERVANCY IS THAT-
BETWEEN JUST CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE-
IDENTIFIED SOME SPECIFIC
PROJECTS BUT- THE OTHER
CONSERVANCY'S AREN'T EXACTLY
LEFT OUT OF THIS IT'S THERE AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HISTORICALLY.
USED BY NUMBER CONSERVANCY IS
TO DO SEVERAL PROJECTS EFFECT
ACTUALLY THE FRAMEWORK. UNDER
FIRE ENGINE PACKAGES ACTUALLY
TO USE THE- CONSERVATIONS
REGIONAL FOREST AND FIRE
CAPACITY GRANT PROGRAM TO KIND
OF BUILD UP. AND DEVELOP
REGIONAL COLLABORATIONS AND
STRATEGIC PLANS TO GET PROJECTS
IN THE PIPELINE AND SO THERE'S
INVESTMENTS IN THAT PROGRAM TO
HELP- ALL OF THE CONSERVANCY'S
AND ALL OF THE LOCAL. ENTITIES
TO BE ABLE TO WORK ON-
ADDITIONAL REGIONAL PLANNING
AND THEN THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
MONEY. IN THE FOREST HEALTH AND
FIRE PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAMS
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM- THAT
ARE ALL ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
UNCERTAINTIES AS WELL AS LOCAL
ENTITIES TO COMPETE FOR AN TO
DO THOSE PROJECTS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT ANSWER I'D I DO FEEL
OBLIGED TO REMIND US THAT THE
CREEK FIRE WHICH IS THE LARGEST
FIRE WE'VE HAD IN OUR STATE
HISTORY. BEGAN IN FRESNO
COUNTY. AND MUCH OF THE
PREVENTION WORK THAT WE ARE
SPEAKING TO TODAY IS IN FUEL
REDUCTION. AND THAT THERE ARE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS FOR US TO
ADDRESS THE BEETLE KILLED.
TREES THAT WE CAN HELP TO
REDUCE AND I'M WONDERING. AND
IT CAN BE A CONTINUED
CONVERSATION BUT I DO FEEL LIKE
REMINDING US THAT IT SEEMS WE
CONTINUE TO FUND THE
CONSERVANCY'S THAT ARE ON THE
COAST. BUT WE LEAVE OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
ONES THAT STRUGGLE. TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE THEIR- WITH AND A-
SHARE OF RESOURCES AND JUST
WOULD ASK THAT WE CONTINUE TO
REMEMBER THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY. AS THESE
DISCUSSIONS ARE GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU DOCTOR AVAILABLE GO TO MR
GALLAGHER IN THE MISCHIEVOUS.
ALL RIGHT IT'LL BE NOBODY'S
SURPRISE THAT I WANT TO FOCUS
ON WILDFIRE- AND SO. LET ME I
WANT TO DIG THROUGH SOME OF
THESE THINGS BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT HISTORY- WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE NINE OH
ONE DEAL- WHICH WAS A
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT I
THINK OF THIS LEGISLATURE-
SENATOR DOLLY I KNOW PLAYED A
VERY KEY ROLE- IN NEGOTIATING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. FROM GIGI R. F. THAT
WOULD BE PART OF THAT. OF THAT
PACKAGE TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE
DOING- NOT EVERYTHING BUT
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT ON THE MONEY GOING
INTO- WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
FUELS REDUCTION- ONE THING IS
MISSING FROM THIS PACKAGE IS
THERE WAS A LOT OF REPUBLICAN
INFLUENCE. ON NINE OH ONE AND
AS FAR AS I KNOW NONE OF US
WERE ASKED TO BE PART OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS ON THIS PACKAGE
AND I THINK THAT'S PROBLEMATIC.
ESPECIALLY ONE AS MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN BURNING
DOWN. WE NEED TO BE PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION GOING FORWARD
AND I WAS MISSING AND I THINK
THAT'S A PROBLEM- ON THE NINE
OH ONE DEAL IS SUPPOSED TO BE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. A YEAR-
LAST YEAR AS I UNDERSTAND IT WE
DID NOT GET THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION BECAUSE OF THE GDR OF
FUND NOT THE OPTION NOT
GENERATING ENOUGH MONEY. IS
THAT CORRECT AND- WAS THAT
MONEY MADE UP AT ALL IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. I'LL HAVE A
QUESTION TO STEVEN BENSON. GOOD
MORNING CEMEX GALLAGHER YES SO
THIS PACKAGE INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND GIGI R. F. THAT IS TO MAKE
UP THE DIFFERENCE FOR THE-
PORTION OF THE TWENTY MILLION
THAT WAS NOT ORIGINALLY
INCLUDED. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. OKAY SO THAT MAKES
UP FOR LAST YEAR OKAY. AND THEN
DO WE DO THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S COMMITTED FOR
THIS YEAR. YES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSED THE G. G. R. F.
TO TAKE PLACE IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AS ORIGINALLY
PLANNED IN ADDITION THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ACTUALLY
PROPOSES TO CONTINUE DOING. THE
L. S. B. NINE A ONE COMMITMENT
FOR AN ADDITIONAL. FOUR FIVE
YEARS BEYOND WHAT SB NINE A
ONE. PROPOSED RIGHT BUT I WANT
TO GET TO WHERE SO. THE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MAKES UP FOR LAST
YEAR. RIGHT AND THIS YEAR
THERE'S A PROPOSAL FOR ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED MILLION OF GIGI R.
F. RIGHT. YES OKAY SO THAT'S A-
THAT'S THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION. HOW DID THIS FIVE
HUNDRED THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THE JUST GETS US
BACK TO STATUS QUO NINE OH ONE.
RIGHT IF I COULD CLARIFY THE
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION THAT'S AN EARLY ACTION
DOES NOT INCLUDE. BUDGET ALL
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IN CURRENT YEAR WHICH IS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO IT INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO MAKE THE GINGER OF
COMMITMENT HOLE IN INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND- SB NINE A ONE
COMMITMENTS IN FORCED PREVENT
OUR FIRE PREVENTION AND FOREST
RESILIENCE OKAY ALL RIGHT. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT IS NOT ALL
FUELS REDUCTION RIGHT. IT WON'T
ALL BE FUELS REDUCTION THERE IS
SOME THINGS IN THERE TO HELP
DEVELOP THE FOR SECTOR AS AN
ECONOMIC STIMULUS TYPE OF
THINGS. BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE FUNDING IS GOING TO
FOREST HEALTH. AND FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS AS WELL AS
REGIONAL FORCING FOR CAPACITY
GRANTS THERE'S ALSO A- AT.
HEARING ALL THAT TO SAY A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF
THIS FIVE HUNDRED THE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT JUST MAKES UP FOR
WHAT WE DIDN'T DO LAST YEAR
OKAY SO LET'S NOT ACT LIKE
THAT'S ADDITIONAL THAT'S WHAT
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO DO. AND
DIDN'T DO OKAY. SO THAT THE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TAKE THAT OUT OF TAKE THAT OUT
OF THE PICTURE. NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO
ADDITIONAL. THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET I UNDERSTAND THAT. AND
NOW YOU HAVE THIS ADDITIONAL
LET'S CALL IT. YOU KNOW THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION. NOT
ALL OF IT IS GOING INTO FUELS
REDUCTION. RIGHT NOT EVERY LAST
PENNY IS IN FUEL REDUCTION
RIGHT THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT THAT'S GOING TO FUEL
REDUCTION BUT THERE ARE OTHER
ASPECTS OF FOREST HEALTH AND
FIRE PREVENTION BETTER NOT JUST
FUELS REDUCTION RIGHT NOW AND
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO COMBINE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
WITH THE EARLY ACTION THE EARLY
ACTION INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION BEYOND THE SB
NINE A ONE OUNCE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT THAT'S BEYOND
JUST THE S. B. .ORG. SO BETWEEN
EARLY ACTION AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THERE WOULD BE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN FIRE PREVENT
RIGHTLY AND YUKONERS OKAY BUT
AGAIN YOU'RE OBFUSCATING
BECAUSE OF A BIG CHUNK OF THAT
MONEY IS NOT GOING INTO FUELS
REDUCTION. IT'S GOING INTO A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS. AT FOR
INSTANCE I MEAN I'LL GET TO
THIS POINT YOU YOU ANNOUNCE
YOU'RE HIRING A ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED NINETY NINE. NEW
FIREFIGHTERS TO SUPPRESS FIRE.
IN ACTUALITY WE ALWAYS HIRE
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS. YOU'RE
JUST DOING IT EARLIER IN TIME
THIS YEAR. SO THOSE AREN'T NEW
FIREFIGHTERS THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING ON. THAT'S THE SAME
FORCE THAT WE HAVE EVERY YEAR.
CORRECT BUT YOU'RE JUST BRING
IN AMMAN EARLIER IN TIME AND
ANNOUNCING LIKE IT'S SOME
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF PEOPLE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE EVERY YEAR
RIGHT. NOT NOT QUITE- WE DO
BRING ON SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS
AND RECENT YEAR YEAH WE BRING
ON SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS EVERY
YEAR. BUT WE ARE BRINGING ON
MORE SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS THIS
YEAR THAN WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY.
RIGHT BUT YOU'RE INCLUDING IN
THAT ACTING LIKE WHEN YOU
ANNOUNCES YOU ACT LIKE YOU'RE
BRINGING ON MORE FIREFIGHTERS
YOU KNOW ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MORE
FIREFIGHTERS AND WE EVER DO
THAT'S NOT AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT. WE ALWAYS HAVE BRING
ON SEASONAL CREWS AS WE SHOULD.
THE PROBLEM IS. THE PROBLEM IS
THESE FIRE FIRE AND IF YOU TALK
TO THE ACTUAL FIREFIGHTERS
WHICH I DO. THEY THEY WILL TELL
YOU THAT THESE KIND OF FIRES.
THEY'RE NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN
SUPPRESS THEY HAVE THEIR SUCH
CONFLAGRATIONS WITH THE AMOUNT
OF FUEL. THAT WE HAVE THE FUELS
BUILDUP THAT'S OCCURRED OVER
DECADES. ISN'T IT THEY QUICKLY
BECOME LIFESAVING MISSIONS
ONLY. NOT FIRE SUPPRESSION
BECAUSE YOU YOU LITERALLY CAN'T
GET IN FRONT OF THEM. YOU
LITERALLY CAN'T STOP THEM.
BECAUSE OF THE FUELS ISSUE AND
SO WE NEED TO BE PUTTING THE
FOCUS ON FUELS NOW LET'S NOT
DISCUSSION. SO YOU HAVE. 20% OF
THE MONEY BY MY CALCULATIONS
GOES TO CONSERVANCIES. AND
PARKS AND STATE OWNED LANDS BUT
WE ALWAYS SAY IT'S NOT REALLY
THE STATE ON LANDS THE PROBLEM
IS THE FEDERAL LAND. LIKE WHERE
THEY CAN'T FIRE STARTED FOR
INSTANCE. LIKE WHERE THE BEAR
FIRE STARTED ON FEDERAL LAND
AND BURNED OUT THE COMMUNITY
OF- AND SORRY BURNED OUT THE
COMMUNITY A VERY CREEK THIS
YEAR. THEY START ON FEDERAL
LAND WE NEED TO BE DOING THE
WORK OUT THERE ON FEDERAL LAND
YET 20% OF THIS MONEY IS GOING
TO CONSERVANCIES AND STATE
OWNED LANDS. WHICH MAKE UP
ABOUT 3% OF THE LAND MASS. THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH RIGHT. SO
WHY NOT BUILD ABILITIES MISTER
GALLAGHER BUT THE STATE OWNED
LANDS IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
WHICH IS WHY WOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MANAGE THAT.
IN THE MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING
IS GOING TOWARD SUPPRESSION IS
BECAUSE GOING TOWARD A NOT
SUPPRESSION. BUT TO VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. 20% IS GOING TO
STATE OWNED LANDS EVEN THOUGH
THEY REPRESENT 3% OF THE
PROBLEM AND WE JUST ANNOUNCED
WE HAD A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT IN
AUGUST OF LAST YEAR. ABOUT THIS
NEW PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO A
MILLION ACRES A YEAR. WHICH WE
HAVE NOT MET. WE HAVE NOT MET A
MILLION ACRES HERE THAT IS NOT
TRUE. WE'RE NOT ON TRACK TO DO
THAT AND YET WE'RE PROPOSING TO
TAKE 20% OF THE MONEY HERE. AND
FOCUS IT. AND AGAIN. I'M NOT
SAYING THE CONSERVANCY'S DON'T
DO WORK- FOR INSTANCE HERE IN
ABOUT A CONSERVANCY HAS DONE A
LOT OF WORK IN THIS SPACE
THAT'S WHY THEY ACTUALLY WERE.
IN THE EARLIER PROPOSALS THEY-
THEY WERE TARGETED WITH MONEY
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN. MONEY
GOT TARGETED ELSEWHERE THE
PROBLEM IS THIS LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET DOESN'T SPECIFY THAT
THOSE CONSERVANCY IS USE THE
MONEY FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION OR
SORRY FIRE PREVENTION OF FUELS
REDUCTION THEY COULD USE THE
MONEY TO GO BUY ADDITIONAL LAND
OR BY ADDITIONAL EASEMENTS
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
LANGUAGE THE SAYS THEY CAN'T DO
THAT. AND WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT
MONEY'S GOING TO GO TO WHERE
THE REAL PROBLEM IS. WHICH IS
ON FEDERAL LANDS WHERE WE
CONSTANTLY SAY THAT PEOPLE
CONSTANTLY SAY THAT ALMOST A
FEDERAL LANDS PROBLEM. WELL NOW
WE'VE GOT TO DEAL WITH THE FEDS
TO DO A MILLION ACRES A YEAR.
AND WE HAVE MONEY THAT WE CAN
INVEST IN IT LET'S TARGETED.
TOWARDS WHERE THE REAL PROBLEM
IS. WE'RE TALKING LIKE TEN FOOT
TALL BRUSH PILES AND SOME OF
THESE AREAS. YOU'RE NT GOING
TO STOP THAT UNLESS YOU GET RID
OF IT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
DROVE THE CAMPFIRE. THAT'S WHAT
DROVE THE FIRE THAT WIPED OUT
VERY VERY CREEK WE ACTUALLY THE
FEDS LET THAT FIRE BURN. FOR
WEEKS AND THEN IT TOOK OFF AND
CAME THROUGH AND DESTROYED A
WHOLE COMMUNITY. WHY ARE WE
FOCUSING THIS MONEY ON THE
PROBLEM THAT'S MY POINT. YOU'VE
GOT TO GET THAT MONEY TARGETED
TOWARDS A FUELS REDUCTION
PROJECTS THAT ACTUALLY STOP
THESE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING TO THE
TO THE HEART AND HE CORE OF
THE PROBLEM WE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON IT BUT NOW
THAT WE'RE SITTING HERE WITH
MONEY AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE
AN INVESTMENT. IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT MONEY BE TARGETED TOWARDS
THOSE PROJECTS AND I'LL LET.
YOU KNOW MISTER BENSON RESPOND
TO THAT BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR FEEDBACK BUT- I DON'T
THINK THIS PACKAGE TARGETS THAT
SUFFICIENTLY TOWARDS FUELS
REDUCTION BUT I'D LOVE TO GET
YOUR FEEDBACK ON THAT. THIS
PACKAGE IS LARGELY ABOUT FUELS
REDUCTION. WE'RE NOT FUNDING
SPECIFIC PROJECTS ON FEDERAL
LAND BECAUSE THE STATE DOESN'T
HAVE JURISDICTION OF THE
FEDERAL LAND BUT WE AREDOING
PARTNERSHIPS AND REGIONAL
COLLABORATION THAT INCLUDES ALL
LANDOWNERS. FEDERAL STATE
PRIVATE AND WE'RE WORKING ON
PROJECTS THAT ARE DEVELOPED
WITH THOSE REGIONAL
COLLABORATIONS WEBER THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING. AND
HELP TO TAKE CARE OF LAND THAT
IT HAS JURISDICTION OVER NO WE
ALSO USED A BAR GRANTS TO TREAT
THAT ONE LET ME CORRECT YOU ARE
DOING THE GALLAGHER CAN LOOK AT
CAN YOU LET THE GENERAL ANSWER
HIS QUESTION YOU STARTING WITH
YOUR QUESTION. YEAH I JUST BUT
MR BENSON ISN'T IT TRUE MR
GALLAGHER. HE IS DONE FINISH
THE QUESTION HE FINISHED
ANSWERING. GO AHEAD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YEAH SO. MY QUESTION
THOUGH IT I MEAN YOU SAID THIS
ISN'T GOING TOWARDS FEDERAL
LAND ACTUALLY THAT'S NOT TRUE
THE FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS THAT
WE- THAT WE GIVE OUT AS A STATE
THOSE CAN BE USED ON FEDERAL
LAND. I'M SORRY IF THE LAST
PART OF MY COMMENT DIDN'T COME
THROUGH CLEARLY WHAT I WAS
SAYING IS YES WE DO USE SOME OF
OUR GRANT DOLLARS TO DO
PROJECTS ON FEDERAL LAND. THAT
IS CORRECT. RIGHT AND WE HAVE
SOME SIGNIFICANT MONIES IN
THERE BUT I'M SAYING THAT'S
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF PROJECTS
THAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED IN ON
RIGHT NOW IT'S SEVENTY THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. AND FIFTY
MILLION GIGI R. F. IN THOSE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. GRANTS.
BUT WE COULD FOCUS FOR INSTANCE
THAT. THAT 20% IS NOW JUST
FOCUSED ON. STATE LANDS WE
COULD PULL MORE OF THAT MONEY
INTO THE GRANT PROGRAM AND GET
AND GET OUT MORE OF THESE
PROJECTS CORRECT. SO BETWEEN
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS THOSE TWO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THERE IS TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS BEING MADE
AVAILABLE ALL OF THAT GOES
TOWARDS FUEL REDUCTION. IN
FORCE FOR SELF PROJECTS THAT
HELP WITH YOUR REACTION. THE
FORCE WILL PREVENTION GRANTS
ARE MORE SPECIFIC TO FUELS
BREAKS AND THOSE TYPES OF
SPECIFIC PROJECTS. BUT FORCED
HEALTH GRANTS ALSO HELPED
MANAGE THE HEALTHY FOREST.
WHICH HELPS TO MAKE BILL'S
REDUCTION AS WELL. AND THERE'S
ALSO A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
SPECIFIC TO SMALL LANDOWNERS
AND THERE'S FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE AND
HAND CREWS THAT ARE ALSO ABOUT
FUELS REDUCTION. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT GRANT
PROGRAMS IN HERE THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON FUELS REDUCTION I
WOULD SAY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THIS EVEN THE STATE PROJECTS
FOR PARKS AND FISH AND THE
CONSERVANCIES ARE FOCUSED ON
FUELS REDUCTION. AND FIRE
PREVENTION. MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
LAST QUESTION IS SO I JUST
DECLARE I MEAN I THINK THAT WAS
GOOD THAT SUMMED IT UP IS TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TOWARDS
REAL FUELS REDUCTION. OUT OF
THIS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I THINK
THAT WAS GOOD TO HIGHLIGHT. AND
THEN. BUT YOU CAN PUT A LOT OF
MONEY TO PROJECTS BUT WE NEED
TO DO THE STREAMLINING OF
SEQUEL- IN ORDER TO GET. OUT
THESE PROJECTS THE
ADMINISTRATION DID THIRTY FIVE.
STREAMLINED PROJECTS THAT THAT
I APPLAUD THEM ON. HOW MANY
MORE ARE WE DOING. WITH THIS
MONEY UNDER THAT SAME SEEK WAS
STREAMLINING BECAUSE IF YOU IF
YOU DON'T REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS
YOU COULD HAVE MONEY LIKE VERY
CREEK DID THEY HAVE THE MONEY.
TO DO FOR FUELS MANAGEMENT
AROUND THE TOWN BUT THEY HAD TO
GO THROUGH A FULL SEQUEL-
REVIEW AND THEY WERE STOPPED
HIM SHE WILL NOT WORK SO WHAT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION DOING ARE
WE DOING DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
PROJECTS UNDER THAT STREAMLINED
METHOD. OR NOT. SO I DON'T
REMEMBER THE EXACT DATE BUT
RECENTLY THE CAL VTP THE
CALIFORNIA- VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAM. WAS
APPROVED- WHICH ACTUALLY
STREAMLINED SEQUEL FOR
STATEWIDE FOR PROJECTS THAT FIT
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THAT AND
MOSTLY THESE FUELS REDUCTION
AND FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS WILL
FIT WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THE
DOUBT BE COMPETE. SO THERE IS A
BROAD STREAMLINED SEQUEL
ALREADY IN PLACE- BASED ON THE
COMPLETION OF THAT PLANT. HOW
MANY PROJECTS. I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY PROJECTS TO BE
FUNDED WITH THE GRANTS THAT
WILL DEPEND ON THE GROUNDS THAT
ARE PROPOSED ARE THE- PROPOSAL
PROJECTS AND PROPOSED AND WHICH
ONES GET AWARDED- AS WE NOTED.
THAT A LARGE PORTION OF THIS
MONEY IS IN COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS SO A LARGELY DEPEND ON
WHICH PROJECTS PROPOSED NOTABLY
GET AWARDED OBVIOUSLY IF THAT'S
A WHOLE BUNCH OF- LARGE DOLLAR
PROJECTS TO BE FEWER NUMBER
PROJECTS IF IT'S- ON A LARGE
NUMBER OF SMALL DOLLAR PROJECTS
THEN DIDN'T THE NUMBER PROJECTS
WITH VERY. IT JUST DEPENDS ON
THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS. THAT
WILL BE GOOD I KNOW WHAT THAT
NUMBER IS WE DID THIRTY FIVE
UNDER THAT STREAMLINED PROCESS-
PROCESS- IT'S UNCLEAR HOW MANY
MORE WE'RE GOING TO DO AND AS
WE KNOW. THIS PROBLEM IS HUGE
WE'VE GOT TO GET OUT IT WE HAVE
TO DOUBLE DOWN. REALLY ON OUR
EFFORTS PROBLEM IS I DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE'RE DOING THAT WITH THIS
PACKAGE. PROCEDURE CONCERNS I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THIS
PROBABLY MORE THAN DOUBLES DOWN
ON THE AMOUNT OF ACTUAL FIRE
PREVENTION FUELS REDUCTION WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU WERE GOING TO
GO TO MISS REVERSE AND TO
MISTER SMITH NEXT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND-
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOUR WORK ON
THESE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
BUDGET BILLS. ARE YOU KNOW I. I
WANNA START OFF- BY MAKING
COMMENTS ON S. B. EIGHTY FIVE
IT ECHOING THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA I
ARE BUDGET SUB THREE CHAIR
MADE. ON THANKING THE TEAM THAT
WAS INVOLVED IN THESE
NEGOTIATIONS INCLUDING THE
SENATE WORKING GROUP- A TEAM
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. AND OF
COURSE OF NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE STAFF WERE INVOLVED
SO THANK YOU TO ALL THAT MADE
THIS HAPPEN. AND ALL WITH A
FOCUS ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE- SPENDING MONEY OR EARLY ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EARLY THIS
YEAR AHEAD. OF THE WILDFIRE
SEASON- I ALSO WANT TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS ON. OF SB NINETY
THREE AND THE RIGHT TO RETURN
POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THAT BILL. I DON'T
SEVERAL MEMBERS HAVE MADE. HAVE
ASK QUESTIONS AND I HOPE THAT
THEY GET ANSWERS TO THEIR
QUESTIONS TODAY SO THAT THEY
CAN MAKE THEIR DECISION. BUT I
THINK THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT COVERT HAS ABSOLUTELY
DISSEMINATED OUR HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY. AND THEIR EMPLOYEES-
IN AB I MEAN SB NINETY THREE
CONTAINS PROVISIONS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING THAT
THOSE WHO WANT TO WORK HAVE A
PATHWAY BACK TO EMPLOYMENT. OF
THIS BILL. IS DIFFERENT FROM
THE BILL THAT WAS VETOED LAST
YEAR INCLUDING. THE REMOVAL OF
PRIVATE RIGHT TO ACTION THE
INCLUSION OF A SUNSET DATE ON
IT I THINK. IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT WE ALREADY ALL VOTED
FOR LAST YEAR. ON IT I HOPE
THAT. YOU'LL JOIN ME IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- AS A MEMBER OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS I CAN SAY
THAT THE MAJORITY. OF THESE
WORKERS. IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY TEND TO BE PEOPLE OF
COLOR- AND WE REALLY NEED TO
TREAT THAT. WITH THE DIGNITY
AND RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE-
AFTER THIS CRISIS SO THANK YOU
TO ALL. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
MISTER SMITH AND THEN MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ON IT IN REGARDS TO IT SB
EIGHTY FIVE. ITEM NUMBER FIVE
FIRE PREVENTION PROJECT
PROJECTS. TEN MILLION DOLLARS
I'D LIKE TO SEE THE LIST OF
PROJECTS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT MIGHT BE ON THAT
PROJECT LIST. IS THERE A
PROJECT LIST. WHICH WHICH TO
MENTAL APPROPRIATIONS REFERRING
TO A CAMERA WITH WHICH TEN
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
ARE YOU REFERRING TO SIR MARCUS
OF ITEM NUMBER FIVE. FIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS SO FAR
THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER ONE SUB
ITEM FIVE. YES SORRY I WAS
LOOKING UP ON THE AGENDA- SO
THAT IS THE FUNDING THAT WILL
GO TO CAL FIRE UNITS FOR FIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS I DON'T
KNOW THAT THE EXACT PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED YET SO
EACH EACH CAL FIRE UNIT HAS A
LIST OF PROJECTS AND IT
MAINTAINS- FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES THEIR AREAS THAT
ARE KIND OF HIGHEST PRIORITY- I
THINK WHAT IS YET TO BE.
DETERMINED AND I CAN CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP TO FIND OUT THERE'S
MORE INFORMATION ON IS HOW MUCH
OF THE TEN MILLION GO TO EACH-UNIT AND THEN YOU KNOW THOSE
UNITS WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE AND
WHAT PROJECTS IT WOULD FUND
WITH THAT SO I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE HAVE THAT LIST RIGHT NOW BUT
WE CAN WE CAN CERTAINLY TALK TO
FOLKS AND SEE WHAT'S AVAILABLE
OKAY AND PROBABLY COULD. EVEN
ITEM NUMBER NINE IS FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION FROM HOME HOME
HARDENING. IN NUMBER ELEVEN TWO
MILLION FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTORS. WHAT I'M GETTING AT
IS THEY NEED MORE MONEY. LIKE
TO SEE A LIST OF PROJECTSTHAT
THEY NEED DONE. SO MAYBE WE CAN
FIND THEM. COME JUNE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS
BUDGET. TO TRY TO GET THESE
PROJECTS. OF FOR FIRE
PREVENTION. WE'RE ALL WE ALL
KNOW HOW BAD. IT IS IN THE
STATE. WE KEEP PUTTING IT OFF
WE NEED TO PUT THE MONEY. ON
THE GROUND. FOR THESE RESOURCES
TO TAKE AFFECT. THANK YOU- SB
NINETY TWO- THE REALIGNMENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND YOU SAID
THERE WAS EVERYBODY WAS IN THE
NEGOTIATION TO COULD YOU TALK
TO FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY. DISTRICT
COUNTIES TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
RESOURCES WE KEEP PUSHING
FUNDING FROM THE STATE DOWN TO
THE COUNTIES. BUT THE MONEY
DOESN'T COME WITH IT. AND
HOWARD HILL SMALL COUNTIES
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE OVER
D. J. J'S PROGRAM THIS RUN SO
GOOD IN THE STATE. THIS IS
ALICE IN. OKAY GO AHEAD THEIR
CAT I WAS JUST GONNA TURN IT TO
ALISON I THINK YELTSIN. HI
ALISON HEWITT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CERTAINLY I DID NOT
TALK WITH ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES BUT WE TALKED WITH.
THE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES-
WHICH I BROADLY SPEAKING AND
THAT IS KIND OF REPRESENTING
COUNTY INTERESTED THEN WE
TALKED WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FOLKS I SOME OF WHOM
ARE INVOLVED IN THE ROLE
COUNTIES. THERE ARE NONE AND IF
STOCKTON FEEDBACK OR INTEGRATED
HERE AND I WOULD ALSO SAY TO
THE AMOUNT OF USE THAT
ACCOUNTING HAS TO SERVE IT IS
SOMEWHAT I'M DEPENDENT ON KIND
OF THE YOUTH POPULATION THAT
THEY HAVE- THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
GO TO DJ JERRY. AND THE OTHER
TWO AND THEN THEY KEPT THE
FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED WOULD
GO TO ALL COUNTIES- DEPENDING
DEPENDING ON THE AMOUNT OF USE
I'M- NOT THEY'LL SERVE A REAL
LIFE YOU THAT THEY'LL SERVE IN
THEIR CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT. THAT AND WHAT I SPEAK
NINETY TWO SEEKS TO DO AGAIN AS
I IT HAD- KIND OF NOTED EARLIER
IS PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COUNTIES TO CONTRACT WITH OTHER
COUNTIES ARE POTENTIALLY OR TO
USE. AND NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS THERE'S A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT
COUNTIES WITH HOT A WITH THE
HOPE THAT AND FOR EXAMPLE RURAL
COUNTIES AND MAY ANT TO SEEK
OUT AND SOME OTHER OPTIONS. AS
OPPOSED TO- RIGHT IN THEIR OWN
SANDEL PROGRAM THAT THEY MIGHT
PARTNER OTHER CAN HAS I'M
PRETTY. ROLE COUNT IS UNDER
THAT THE IN OPTION THAT BE
ABOUT. D. J. J'S PROBE IS JUST
RUN FINE IN THIS. MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED IT. BUT NOW
WE'RE GONNA PUSH INTO THE
COUNTIES AND THEY GOT A WHOLE
START THOUGH WHAT I CALL THE
START THE WHOLE WHEEL OF THE
PROCESS ALL OVER AGAIN TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
THEM. BUT I WON'T KEEP GOING
TOO MUCH BUT MY BIG CONCERN
WITH THIS BILL IS. JUVENILE
JUSTICE BUT YOU'RE GONNA BUT
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD. ADULTS
WITH CHILDREN. AND I HAVE A
MAJOR PROBLEM WITH THAT PART OF
IT. I'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO NINETY FOUR. BIT SB NINETY
THREE BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING
SHORT OF TIME WE'RE PROBABLY
ALREADY OVER. ANOTHER ONE IS.
CONCERNING FOR THE EMPLOYERS IN
THIS STATE WE'RE TRYING TO OPEN
UP THE STATE GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. BUT THE EMPLOYEE. THAT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER. GET FIVE
DAYS I GOT A CALL YOU. COULD
BRING YOU BACK TO WORK. YOU
HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO RESPOND I
NEED SOMEBODY TO SHOW UP FOR
WORK TOMORROW IN MY BUSINESS.
THIS DOES NOT MAKE THAT HAPPEN
IN THE STATE. THAT IS A BIG
PROBLEM WE NEED TO GET THE
STATE BACK OPEN. IT IF THEY'RE
WILLING TO GO TO WORK. CHAU
FILL OUT THE APPLICATION AND
SHOW UP FOR WORK ME AS AN
EMPLOYER. IS HINDERED ROUGHLY
FORTY DAYS BEFORE I CAN HIRE.
THAT EMPLOYEE BECAUSE I HAVE TO
WAIT FOR AN ANSWER FOR MY PAST.
EMPLOYEE AND I THINK THERE'S A
BIG PROBLEM THIS BILL SHORTEN
TIME THANK YOU. MAY I JUST
CONFIRM THAT IT IS ACTUALLY-
WITHIN FIVE BUSINESS DAYS THE
EMPLOYER NEEDS TO NOTIFY AN
EMPLOYEE AND THAT EMPLOYEE THAT
HAS FIVE BUSINESS DAYS TO
RESPOND SO IT'S ONLY THE TEN
DAYS. WE JUST CONFIRMING THE
TIME LINE OKAY. AND I HEARD ONE
OF ONE OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
SPOKE OF THIRTY DAYS AFTER THAT
TO THE STILL HAVE TIME WHERE'S
THAT THIRTY DAYS IN THERE THEN.
I BELIEVE THE EMPLOYER- MUST
RESPOND WITHIN THIRTY DAYS IF
THE POSITION WAS OFFERED TO
ANOTHER EMPLOYEE THAT WAS NOT-
LAID OFF. OKAY IN TEN DAYS BUT
THEN I HAVE SOME OTHER NOTES
THE OTHER BAD PART OF THIS. IF
I DO HIRE SOMEONE. AND I DON'T
SAY I DO IT ON DAY NINE BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM MY
PREVIOUS EMPLOYEE. I'M GONNA BE
FINED A HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
EACH EMPLOYEE. UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES. BECAUSE I'M TWENTY
FOUR HOUR SHORT OF ADHERED TO
THIS LAW. I THINK IS BAD POLICY
EXPRESSLY FOR THE BUSINESS
OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO MISTER BENNETT AND
THEN TO MISS KOREA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR OF I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS MY
COMMENTS- PRIMARILY TO SB
EIGHTY FIVE THE WILDFIRE- BILLS
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US-
THIS IS A MAJOR EXPANSION OF
OUR PREVENTION EFFORTS- AS A
POINTED OUT BY MY COLLEAGUE-
FROM SANTA MONICA. AND BECAUSE
THIS IS A NEW EFFORT- THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SIGNIFICANT
LEARNING CURVE. WE HAVEN'T BEEN
IN THE BUSINESS OF. PUTTING A
LOT OF FOCUS ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. AND AS AGAIN AS MY
COLLEAGUE- POINTED OUT THE WE
HAVE TREMENDOUS VARIETY AND
VEGETATION GEOGRAPHY- AND
CLIMATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT CREATES A WIDE VARIETY OF
FIRE RISK- FROM BEETLE
INFESTATIONS IN THE SIERRA
FOOTHILLS- WHERE FIRES MAY
COMMENT A WHOLE WALL OF FLAMES
TO CHAPARRAL. OF FIRE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFONIA. SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. I ENCOURAGE US TO
DEVELOP POLICIES TO CAPTURE
LESSONS LEARNED THIS FIRST YEAR
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST. A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS PERHAPS ANOTHER
BILLION DOLLARS LET'S GET THE
LESSONS LEARNED LET'S LET'S
LEARN HOW TO RANK PROJECTS
WHICH TURNED OF VALUE WAIT. A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF THESE
PROJECTS- SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
BETTER IDEA NEXT YEAR. WHAT ARE
THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WE
SHOULD MAKE ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL INVESTMENTS WE COULD
MAKE- WHICH THINGS UP MAKE THE
MOST SENSE FROM A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT SECOND MY SECOND
POINT IS THAT. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY SPOT FIRES
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WERE
THE PREDOMINANT WAY. THAT
STRUCTURE WERE LOST. EXCUSE ME.
THEY WERE THE PREDOMINANT WAY
THAT STRUCTURES WERE LOST AND
IT SEEMS THAT. THE SCIENCE AND
THE THOUGHT GIVEN. TO HOW TO
DEAL WITH SPOT FIRES- IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE
DEVELOPED MORE OF BECAUSE THERE
THAT DID DID THE RANDOM NATURE
OF WHAT STRUCTURES WERE LOST X.
CETERA SUGGEST IT'S NOT THE
SAME AS A WALL OF FLAME- THAT
WENT THROUGH PARADISE AND WE
NEED TO HAVE A GOOD FIRE
PREVENTION TECHNOLOGY FOR BOTH
OF THESE AND I JUST HOPE WE
HAVE A HEALTHY RESPECT FOR HOW
MUCH WE HAVE TO LEARN. IN THIS
AREA TWO OTHER THINGS I JUST
LIKE TO POINT OUT HAS REACHED
ALL THE COMMENTS HERE NUMBER
ONE I WAS ELECTED BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE- HEARING- AT WE
A WAS IDENTIFIED
WANT TO- RESPOND MY COLLEAGUES-
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION IN THE NUMBER OF
FIREFIGHTERS AS STAFF POINTED
OUT HERE TODAY IT'S NOT JUST
HIRING THE SEASONAL ONES WE
HAVE NOW SOONER. BUT THERE IS
ALSO ACTUAL BODIES MORE
FIREFIGHTERS BEING HIRED WE
SPECIFICALLY HAD- THE DATE ON
THAT AND I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF
ME BUT- THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION AND THEN- THE FINAL
THING I HAVE IS A RELATED TO-
THE QUESTION IS COMING UP ABOUT
THE HOSPITALITY BILL AND I JUST
LIKE TO HAVE SAFF CLARIFY
BECAUSE I THINK I'VE HEARD.
SOME CONFUSION HERE- THE- DAY.
IS THIRTY DAYS A BUSINESS OWNER
HAS TO RESPOND WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS. IF THEY CHOSE NOT TO HIRE
SOMEBODY BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE
QUALIFICATIONS AND THEY HIRED
SOMEBODY ELSE BECAUSE THEY SAY
THAT. PERSON HAD THE
QUALIFICATIONS YOU DON'T. GIVE
THAT. IN THAT- NOT AS LIKELY.
OR NOT A FREQUENT AS- THAT'S
ONE THE EMPLOYEE HAS TO REACH.
IN TELL EMPLOYEE THAT DIDN'T
GET HIRED. THAT WHAT. WHAT WERE
THE QUALIFICATIONS THE OTHER
PER AND WHY YOU WEREN'T. STAFF
FOR MY CORRECT IN THAT THE IT'S
FOR ALL OF THEIR HIRING AND
THAT THEY HAVE TO WAIT THIRTY
DAYS COULD STAFF HELP ME WITH
THAT PLEASE. THERE WAS A LOT TO
DIGEST AND ALL OF THESE BILLS
OVER THE WEEKEND. THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY YOU ARE CORRECT ON
THAT RIGHT SO WHEN WE HEAR THIS
THIRTY DAYS THIS THIRTY DAYS IS
NOT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
EMPLOYEES ARE GOING TO BE
OFFERED THE JOB THEY'RE GONNA
TAKE IT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
OFFERED A JOB THEY'RE NOT GONNA
TAKE IT AND THEN IT'S THE NEXT
EMPLOYEE AND ALL OF THE
EMPLOYEES ARE TO BE NOTIFIED AT
THE SAME TIME- TO TRY TO SPEED
THIS ALONG STRONGLY NOTIFIED
THAT YOUR SECOND LINE IF THIS
PERSON DOESN'T TAKE IT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET IT. BUT AND PLAYER
DOES NOTHAVE TO WAIT THIRTY
MORE DAYS BEFORE THEY ACTUALLY
OFFER THE JOB SOMEBODY JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT ONE FINAL
TIME. CORRECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING UP ALL THESE VERY
IMPORTANT OF PROPOSALS TO US
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
BUDGET STAFF IN OUR LEGISLATIVE
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THESE BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO PRIORITIZE
THEM MOVE THEM FORWARD AND GET
THEM TO THE GOVERNOR SAYS. I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF DISNEYLAND RE OPENING ONE OF
OUR STATE'S LARGEST EMPLOYERS I
SAID TO RE OPEN AT A LIMITED
CAPACITY I BELIEVE ON APRIL
THIRTIETH I LOVE DISNEYLAND I
THINK IT'S A MAGICAL PLACE BUT
WHAT MAKES IT SPECIAL AND
MAGICAL ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE THAT BRING IT TO
LIFE. AND WHAT I AM MOST
EXCITED ABOUT IS OUR ABILITY IN
THIS BODY TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
THE NECESSARY POLICIES TO
ENSURE THAT WORKERS THAT MAKE A
PLACE LIKE THE THING LINE AND
SO MANY OTHER SO MAGICAL ALSO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN
TO WORK SPECIFICALLY HOTEL
WORKERS THAT HELPED CREATE THE
WONDER THAT WE ALL LOVE SO
MUCH. PUNISHER TWO THINGS
RELATED TO COVER NINETEEN
THAT'S A ISSUES ON UNEMPLOYMENT
AS WELL AS COVER NINETEEN LIVES
LOST A UCLA STUDY RELEASED IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR SHOWS THAT
LATINOS WORKING AS AN ESSENTIAL
SECTORS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN LATINOS ARE THE
MAJORITY OF WORKERS WHO WORK IN
THE FIELDS OF AGRICULTURE
HOSPITALITY AND SANITATION WHAT
THE LUXURY OF WORKING FOM HOME
WAS NOT POSSIBLE AND THANKS TO
THESE WORKERS. CALIFORNIANS
WERE ABLE TO STAY HOME AND
PEOPLE ACROSS OUR NATION HAD
ACCESS TO PRODUCE GROWN IN OUR
STATE OVERALL AT THE FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR NINETEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA LATINOS HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN FAR MORE THAN ANY RACE
OR ETHNICITY. IN OUR STATE WHEN
IT COMES TO UNEMPLOYMENT CLOSE
240% OF ALL CALIFORNIANS JOBS
LOST DURING THE PANDEMIC HAVE
BEEN IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WITH LATINO WORKERS
BEING DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED IN THE SECTOR NEARLY.
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND LAID OFF
HOSPITALITY WORKER IS COULD
RETURN TO. UNDER THIS BILL
UNDER- SB NINETY THREE. AND BE
ABLE TO FIND SOME SENSE OF
NORMALCY AS WE CONTINUE TO
SAFELY REOPEN OUR STATE AND AS
WE CONTINUE TO CREATE PATHWAYS
FOR BOOSTING OUR ECONOMY THE
PROVISIONS. OF THIS BILL TO
GIVE EMPLOYEES AT LEAST FIVE
DAYS TO RESPONSE TO A RE HIRE
OPPORTUNITY IS MEANT TO ADDRESS
THE REALITY THAT GIVEN COVERT
NINETEEN AND A LOSS OF INCOME
WORKERS MOVED LOST THEIR
APARTMENTS. AND HAVE THEIR MAIL
SENT TO A DIFFERENT ADDRESS
TIME IS NEEDED TO INSURE ANY
CORRESPONDENCE REACHES THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THAT EMPLOYERS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO REACH
OUT AND HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
RECORDS SB NINETY THREE OR AB
EIGHTY FOUR ENSURE THAT WORKERS
IN THE HOSPITALITY SPACE. HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN TO
WORK WITH THE JOBS THAT THEY
PREVIOUSLY HAD THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY VOTED FOR A MUCH BROADER
VERSION OF THIS BILL LAST YEAR
AND IT'S NOW COMING BACK.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
WHILE IT ALSO ADDRESSES THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE SEVERAL
LOCAL CITIES HAVE ALREADY
CREATED EVEN STRONGER
ORDINANCES TO ENSURE THE
HOSPITALITY WORKERS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO RETURN TO WORK TO
THEIR PREVIOUS JOB INCLUDING MY
OWN CITY OF LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO
SANTA CLARA. LONG BEACH AND
PASADENA I WOULD SAY THAT-
YESTERDAY I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR STAIN AT THE SAN DIEGO
CONVENTION CENTER AND IN DOING
SO I ALSO HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO HOSPITALITY WORKERS AT
THE HOTEL RIGHT NEXT DOOR. AND
WHILE THE HOTELS ARE OPENING UP
A SMALL CAPACITY THE WORK FORCE
IS STILL NEEDED. AND IN FACT
ONE LATINO WOMAN WHO I SPOKE TO
SAID I FEEL LIKE I'M WORKING
MUCH HARDER TWICE AS HARD
BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE RETURNED TO
WORK TO BE ABLE TO FULFILL THE
DEMANDS OF THE HOTEL. THIS IS
WHY WE NEED ALL WORKERS TO BE
ABLE TO RETURN TO WORK
APPROPRIATELY WHEN IT IS SAFE-
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR JOBS
BACK. WE HAVE GONE THROUGH A
HUGE HUGE CRISIS IN THE LAST
YEAR A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. WHERE
OUR LIVES HAVE BEEN TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN. AND WE'RE MANY
FAMILIES STUFF. IT IS NOT. OUR
MOMENT OUR UPPER TO ENSURE THAT
THIS LATEST BODY THAT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA THAT GUY. OF STATE
IS CREATING THE- NECESSARY TO
ENSURE. THAT PEOPLE RETURN TO
WORK. CAN HAVE A SENSE OF
NORMALCY CAN RETURN TO THEIR
JOBS. WITHOUT CREATING CABBIE
OUGHT TO THAT THEY'RE NOT
WORTHY ENOUGH OF COMING BACK TO
WORK THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
ADDRESS WHEN IT COMES TO
AGEISM. THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
AND EMPLOYERS BEING ABLE TO
RETURN BEING ABLE TO RE HIRE
THOSE PEOPLE THAT THE WORKERS.
THAT MAKE PLACES LIKE
DISNEYLAND AND SO MANY OTHER
OTHER SUCH AN INCREDIBLE A
PLACE TO VISIT BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY. THIS IS A
BUSINESS ABOUT PEOPLE. IT IS
HOW DO WE PUT PEOPLE FIRST AND
ENSURING THAT AMID ECONOMIC
RECOVERIES POST COLD THE
NINETEEN. WORKERS ARE THE
FRONTLINE OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ESPECIALLY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE UNDER
REPRESENTED. AND OFTEN
MARGINALIZED WORKERS WHO ARE
OFTEN IGNORED THIS IS WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT WHY IT MATTERS AND
WHY THE VALUES THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN OUR BUDGET SAY A
LOT MORE ABOUT. WHO WE ARE AND
WHAT OUR GOAL IS. VERSUS WHAT
WE ONLY SAY WE WANT WE CAN TALK
ABOUT A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WE
CAN REALLY ACTUALLY. ACHIEVE IT
AND ACTUALLY CREATE A ROBUST.
PEARL WORKER. ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PLAN THAT ENSURES THAT WORKERS
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
MARGINALIZED AND VULNERABLE
LIMIT THIS CALL BUT NINETEEN
PACKED I MIGHT. HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN TO WORK
SAFELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CASING THEN
WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE GALLERY. THANK YOU PLEASE
RESTART. QATAR WE TURN THE
MICROPHONE OFF IN THE GALLERY.
I THINK IF TO TURN ON THE FOR
BUTTONS ARE BUTTONED THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTER- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES ON
THE FIRST MEASURE ON THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR. WE DO SUPPORT THE
EARLY ACTION BUDGET- WE BELIEVE
AND HOPE IT IS A DOWN PAYMENT
WITH MORE TO COME IN JUNE. WE
WOULD ALSO URGE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN JUNE TO ADOPT A
NUMBER OF POLICY CHANGES. TO GO
ALONG WITH THE WILDFIRE FUNDING
PROPOSALS WE THINK THAT ONE
PERSON NEEDS TO BE IN CHARGE.
OF ADDRESSING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES TO BE TREATED-
WE ALSO THINK THAT PRESCRIBED
FIRE LIABILITY HAS TO BE
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED SO THAT
IT CAN BE UTILIZED. AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT BIOMASS IS PART OF
THE SOLUTION. SECOND MISTER
CHAIR ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE DO HAVE. OBJECTIONS TO THE
RIGHT OF RECALL MEASURE WE
BELIEVE IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
TO BE DONE IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WE THINK IT OUGHT TO
BE. ADDRESSED THROUGH THE
NORMAL POLICY PROCESS. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHO HAVE SIMILAR
MEASURES THAT HAVE. PROVISIONS
RELATED TO EMPLOY YOUR SIZE AS
WELL AS AN EMPLOYER RIGHT TO
CURE PROVISION. OF THAT OUGHT
TO BE A PART OF THAT PROCESS AS
WELL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. GO TO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT. DEPARTMENT FINANCE AS
AN ANSWER ON THE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR QUESTION. MISLI PLEASE
START. HI YES AFTER-
DISCUSSIONS WITH DR- THE FOR
TOTAL SIX MILLION FUNDS
ALLOCATED THEIR SB ONE FIFTEEN
WILL BE FULLY SPENT BY JUNE OF
THIS YEAR AND SO AN ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATION IS REQUIRED- AND TO
WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT THIS IS
THE SIX MILLION IN SB NINETY
THREE SPECIFIC TWO D. I. R.
SUPPORT NETWORK THIS BILL- AND
THEN- IT'S UNDER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO HAD A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE LABOR CODE-
EXPIRING AT THE SAME TIME AS
THE SUNSET AND I JUST WANTED TO
CONFIRM THAT THAT IS CORRECT.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO CONTINUE TO
PUBLIC COMEDY MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE GALLERY. LET'S
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
PHONE OPERATOR EITHER. YES WE
ARE HERE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT. OUR FIRST WILL COME
FROM LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE TWENTY EUROPEN. GOOD
MORNING JERRY KING AND MEMBERS
AND ASSISTING ENGINEERS FOR THE
COMMUNITY OUTLINES WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY
FIVE CAPPER PRESENT SMALL AND
MID SCALE FAMILY FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S WORKED FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS TO PRESERVE
FAMILY SCALE AGRICULTURE AND
PROMOTE ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY. WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT GOVERNOR NATION PROPOSED
AND THAT LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
HAVE AGREED TO INCLUDE AN EARLY
ACTION THE THREE POINT THREE
FIVE MILLION URGENTLY NEEDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
SMALL MID SIZE AND UNDERSERVED
FARMERS SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE.
THE MYRIAD OF STATE AND FEDERAL
CODE RELIEF PROGRAMS THE THRILL
RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT
INVESTMENT BY THE STATE COULD
HELP LEVERAGE MANY MORE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
RELIEF WE WANT TO SEND A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ID ARE CURRY AND A SEVEN
AG COMMITTEE CHAIR ROBERT LEE.
RIVAS AND YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP DURING. A
CHALLENGING TIME THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU. THANKS WILL
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWENTY ONE EUROPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AT THIS IS JULIE MALINOVSKY
BOTTLE AND SPEAKING ON ITEM D.
S. B. NINETY THREE REPRESENTING
A CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION. THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL AND LODGING ASSOCIATION
BELIEVES. THE NINETY THREE WILL
NOT BRING BACK THE JOB THAT THE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND OUT OF
WORK HOTEL EMPLOYEES AS WRITTEN
IT WILL SLOW THE PROCESS.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE AFTER THREE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THIS BILL
MORE WORKABLE THEIR DETAILS IN
THE LETTER YOU OF ALL RECEIVED
HOWEVER IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
BRINGING THESE EMPLOYEES BACK
WE NEED TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF GAS. AND
DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT MANY
HOTELS STATE FINANCIAL
DISTRESS. THERE ARE NUMBER OF
WAYS THAT THIS LEGISLATURE CAN
HELP THE INDUSTRY ND GREEN
NEED BACK BRING THESE EMPLOYEES
BACK. INCLUDE THE BUDGET-
INCLUDING IN THE BUDGET SB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH INCREASES
FUNDING FOR THE HOLDING OF
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM CALLING ALL
CALIFORNIANS PROGRAMS TO
INCREASE TOURISM IN THE STATE
TO ENACT A STATE FUNDED RE
HIRING INCENTIVES FOR
EMPLOYEES. AND THREE FOND
ENACTED THIS EXCEPT FOR
WASHINGTON DC BRIDGE FUND- IT
IS A JOINTLY RUN LABOR AND
INDUSTRY PROGRAM THE MNEY FROM
THE PROGRAM CAN ONLY BE SPENT
ON PAYROLL AND BENEFITS. WE
NEED TO KEEP THIS CAN MAKE
CONVERSATION GOING TO ENSURE
THAT WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE DOES
BRING BACK HOTEL. EMPLOYEES TO
WORK THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS
SPEAKING ON THE WILDFIRE
FUNDING PORTION OF THAT'S THE
EIGHTY FIVE. AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION WE PARTICULARLY
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR STATE
PARKS. FOR COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION THE FUNDING FOR
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS WE SUPPORT
THE ENTIRE PLAN AND ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO FUTURE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THE
JUNE BUDGET. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
LINE TWENTY FOUR YEAR OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER PER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO SB NINETY
THREE THAT WOULD IMPOSE
SIGNIFICANT BURDENS ON
BUSINESSES IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY THAT HAVE BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AS DISCUSSED AMONG
THE MEMBERS A SIMILAR PROPOSAL
WAS DEBATED AND DISCUSSED THE
POLICY COMMITTEE PROCESS LAST
YEAR WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
BELIEVE SHOULD HAPPEN THIS YEAR
THIS IS A POLICY CHANGE BEING
PUSHED THE BUDGET PROCESS WHICH
IS CONCERNING FROM A PROCEDURAL
PERSPECTIVE. BUT ALSO FROM A
TIMELY NOTICE PERSPECTIVE TO
THOSE IMPACTED AS THEY WILL
HAVE NO NOTICE OF THIS PROPOSAL
WHICH WOULD GO INTO EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY UPON SIGNATURE- AND
THEY WOULD BE CAUGHT OFF GUARD.
ON THE POLICY PERSPECTIVE WE
AGREE THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF FOR NO REASON
OTHER THAN THE SHUTDOWN SHOULD
BE RETIRED AND WILL BE REQUIRED
IT'S COMMONSENSE FROM PLAYERS
TO DO SO AS THEY ARE ALREADY
TRAINED AND QUALIFIED FOR THE
POSITION BUT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
MICROMANAGE HOW AN EMPLOYER
RETIRED EMPLOYEES. SETTING
UNREASONABLE TIME PERIODS TO
OFFER EMPLOYMENT AND NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL ACTUALLY
SLOW DOWN THE HIRING PROCESS
INSTEAD OF IMPROVE IT AND WHILE
WE APPRECIATE AND- APPRECIATE
THAT SB NINETY THREE IS
EXEMPED FROM LITIGATION UNDER
THE LABOR CODE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT WE'RE
STILL CONCERNED WITH THE
MANDATORY ASSESSMENT OF
PENALTIES ON EMPLOYERS WITH NO
DISCRETION TO REDUCE THOSE
PENALTIES. THIS SEEMS
INCONSISTENT WITH MANY OF THE
LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT HAVE
ADOPTED. EXCUSE ME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE ADOPTED
LOCAL ORDINANCES AND INCLUDED A
RIGHT TO CURE PROVISION FOR
EMPLOYERS TO UTILIZE TO AVOID
ANY PENALTIES ONE OTHER THING
WE AGREE WITH THIS POSTON SAID
INTO IS TO- SET AT TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- WHICH SEEMS MUCH
FURTHER THAN NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE PANDEMIC AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE. A REVISION. TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO INSTEAD THANK
YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MMBERS CAITLYN BAKER
FOR UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN AND
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY THAT
LABOR FEDERATION. HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OUR MEMBERS AND-WORKING PEOPLE IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY HAPPENED
DEVASTATED THE NEXT PANDEMIC-
LOCAL ELEVEN HAVE HAD CLOSE
295% UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG THEIR
MEMBERS. AND THE FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING ON AS THEY'VE
BEEN HIT BY THE HARDEST IMPACT
FROM COAL BED AS WELL AS THE
JOB MARKET. ALL THE BILL WOULD
YOU ASK EMPLOYERS RESTORING THE
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE THOSE JOBS
PRIOR TO THAT HAD THAT MAKE
THAT IS THE MINIMUM THAT WE
SHOULD BE ASKING OF EMPLOYER
EXACTLY REBUILD OUR ECONOMY AND
WE ASK. FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON NATALIE MAC SOMETHING
HAPPENED THAT SENSE THAT WE CAN
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT FAVORITE
BUT PLATE MANUFACTURED COUNTY
NATURE FOR ALL IN SUPPORT-
SENATE BILL EIGHTY FIVE THE
WILD FIRE THE EARLY ACTION
WILDFIRE PLANNED- FIRST AND
FOREMOST YOU WANT TO. SAY THAT
AND EXPECT THEIR SUPPORT. FOR
THE PACKAGE IN THE LEGISLATORS
WORK TO APPROPRIATE IMMEDIATE
FUNDS FOR WELFARE PURPOSES. AND
I AND I THINK THAT WE WANT TO
CALL OUT AND FUNDS FOR
CALIFORNIA COASTAL CONSERVANCY
IN STATE PARK WITH STOPS. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ON S. B. NINETY TWO THE
LEGISLATURE AT ACT COUNTY TO
TAKE ON A VERY IMPORTANT NEW
RESPONSIBILITY WITH SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE AND DJJ
REALIGNMENT AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS TODAY. THAT
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
UNDERSTANDING THE LOCAL NEEDS
TO CARRY OUT ITS
RESPONSIBILITY. WE LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
ASPECTS OF SB NINETY TWO WHICH
IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF COUNTIES
TO IMPLEMENT DJJ REALIGNMENT.
HE ALSO BELIEVE THIRD CONTINUED
WORK WE CAN DO TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN IMPLEMENTATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO TRYING TO BUILD
THAT PARTNERSHIP LOCKLEY WE
BELIEVE THE SECURE YOUTH
TREATMENT LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN
SB NINETY TWO. REPRESENTS A
REASONABLE STRUCTURE AND WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE TIME AND
ENERGY THAT ALL PARTIES
INVESTED. IN GETTING THIS DONE
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AS CHAIR
NUMBER THE COMMITTEE CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AT AB DE
END FIVE THIRTY GOING TO
PROVISIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. AND THE
PLAN WILL BE SUPPORTING OUR
REPORT PARENTS AND THE ABILITY
PARK OFFICE USED TO BE ABLE TO
REENTER CARE. AND THAT NEED TO
SUPPORT THE CHILD CARE PROVIDER
TO A SERVING OUR CHILDREN AND
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM I'M REALLY APPRECIATE
EVEN BACK. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR KING IN
MEMBERS DEMOCRATS BURKE ON
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE EARLY
ACTION APPROPRIATIONS FOR
AWHILE CARRIGALINE CONTAINING
SB EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVENTY
NINE. AT THEIR SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING
THE THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. THE REASON FOR DOING
THE TIMING THE SOONER WE CAN
ALLOCATE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FUNDING THE MORE
LIKELY THESE PROJECTS. ARE TO
BE COMPLETED IN ADVANCE OF THE
UPCOMING PARTIES AND WE
APPRECIATE ESPECIALLY THE
FUNDING FOR THE COURSE AFTER
ECONOMIC STIMULUS INCLUDING THE
KIND THE CATALYST FUNDS. AND
FUNDING FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE AND
FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS WHICH
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY
TO REDUCE THE IMPACT OF
WILDFIRES. INCLUDING REDUCING
IMPACT OF SMOKE ON OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES WITH
RESPECT FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ANEXO BOTTOM LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
CALLING REGARDING SB EIGHTY
FIVE. GPA SUPPORTS IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO PREVENT WILDFIRES
THIS YEAR INCLUDING A NUMBER OF
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ARE IN THAT
PACKAGE SUCH AS WILDFIRE
PREVENTION GRANT COMMUNITY HOME
A COMMUNITY AND HOME HARDENING
ALLOCATIONS. AND FEEL GREAT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS DANIELLE SANCHEZ ON THE
HAPPENED THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA
REGARDING AT THE NINETY TWO
WELL WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION AT THIS TIME WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THE POLICY ENACTED
LAST YEAR BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO ALIGN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
COUNTY. THE PROVISIONS AN
ESTIMATE NINETY TWO SUCH AS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SECURE TRACK
AND CLEAR G. TO AVOID NET
WIDENING OR NCREASING ADULT
FILING ARE TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
IN IMPLEMENTATION AT SEVERAL OF
THE QUESTIONS ASKED TODAY I
READ VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
WILL NEED TO WORK WITH THE
STATE ON TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
NEEDS PRESENTED BY THIS
POPULATION. SO WE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION WE APPRECIATE
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK
AND ARE COMMITTED TO THE
CONTINUED WORK TOGETHER TO
FURTHER. SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
SHARON MEMBERS INSIST THAT
BROUGHT I'M BE HAPPENING. HERE
IN THE TEAMSTERS. URGING YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINETY THREE
WHICH IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT. FOR
HOSPITALITY WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE YOU ARE LOOKS AROUND
MEMBERSHIP AT THE HEADED
ENDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
UNEMPLOYMENT. RATE ABOUT 90%
EIGHTEEN CAN'T BEEN USE THE PRE
OF BRING ME BACK OLDER WERE.
I'M BACK WOMEN IN PEOPLE OF
COLOR. VULNERABLE OF OUR WORK.
LIKE WHAT YOU READ LEARNING
HOLCROFT STATE BEING TO NINE
ELEVEN. IT HAD WORKED- WE CAN'T
CLEAN. VERY WELL GETTING BACK
WORK LONGER YOUR STRONG THANK
YOU. KNOCKS OVER THE LINE
THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS A- BERNAY BAYARDO WITH
AS- CAL ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
IN THE FINAL PUBLIC COMMENT WE
HAVE BEEN Q. COMES ONLINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING BOARD MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MIGUEL GARCIA WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M
CALLING REGARDING AN S. B.
NINETY TWO. AT THE FORMER DJJ
YOUTH I FEEL THAT IT WOULD STEP
INTO THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
HOPE THAT YOU CAN VOTE YES ON
IT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS. GREAT
THANK YOU OPERATOR APPRECIATE
YOUR ASSISTANCE ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE GALLERY.
CUTSCENE NONE WE WILL ENSURE.